a couple viral videos showing NBA
players calmly articulately explaining
why they don't want to get the vaccine
has a bunch of journalists and
Democratic activists and politicians
outraged even we're even hearing hearing
from some other celebrities that they
should be kicked off their teams they
should be barred from playing but there
is no mandate apparently in the NBA now
I don't think we're going to see
National Guard being deployed deployed
to replace NBA players who are being
fired but over in North Carolina we have
the biggest the largest mass termination
of Hospital workers due to refusal to
get the vaccine
175 plus workers in North Carolina
hospital and I'm just I just don't
understand why are medical workers such
anti-vaxxers Why are they saying now
that there's a massive portion of New
York Medical workers who are being who
have been fired of this vaccinated these
are people who literally work literally
work in the hospitals don't you think
they would be the least likely to oppose
getting the vaccine perhaps it's just
about Freedom they're like you know we
don't believe that you should be able to
mandate Medical Treatments or perhaps as
medical experts they have a different
expert opinion one that doesn't align
with the mainstream well we're going to
talk about this we're also going to talk
about a lot of what's what's going on uh
going on down to the Border
because we have one of the weirdest
stories I've seen Texas border patrol
uncovers a safe house like a hundred
illegal immigrants and the subheader
says from Fox News and they weren't
wearing PPE
because that's what we're worried about
because the border patrol Agents come to
a house and there's a hundred people
jammed inside of it they're like they're
not wearing covid protective gear yeah
okay we got problems so we are being
joined by a couple of journalists who
are down at the border uh recently
actually with with some evidence of
what's going on there it's crazy stuff
you guys want to you want to introduce
yourself Jorge first yeah I'm a Jorge
Ventura field reporter for the Daily
Caller
um sagnik Basu I'm a producer for the
Daily Caller
you guys were uh down there on the
ground
watching what was going on yeah we've
been uh covering the Border crisis as
soon as it began we were also covering
the the Haitian migrants in Del Rio and
just basically seeing this kind of whole
thing just unfold little by little and
um yeah it's been crazy documentary you
actually brought us a bag of the
bracelets that the Smugglers the human
traffickers make people wear like what
we'll get into all this but you can you
wanna hold one up just people can see
what it is for those that are listening
you can't see anything but those on
YouTube you can see they make the the
the Smugglers make people wear these
bracelets a bunch of them so we'll get
into that that's crazy stuff we got Ian
he's chilling man see in that bracelet
was like one of the most grounding kind
of like smashed into reality things I've
felt in a while thanks that's that's
busted up man the trafficking kids
yeah I took a bunch of them because
they're really interesting and they say
different things so we will get into
them over the course of the show I'm
really looking forward to this because
this is something that needs to be
discussed right now sure but before we
get started head over to timcast.com
become a member and you'll get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
Tim cast iron podcast where actually I
think this week we're gonna be launching
our Mystery Show and we have a new show
called The Green Room which is the fun
hangout which we've been filming so
we're producing a lot of stuff plus we
have a bunch of other shows that are
being produced as we speak it just takes
time this is like you know it's kind of
been a been a shock how fast we've been
growing and so we have all of these pots
going at the same time but we're we're
getting there so stay tuned for that but
don't forget to like this video
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends let's talk about some
NBA because this is really pissing off a
lot of people we got the story from the
Black Wall Street times access is a new
civil right they say with no mandate
some NBA players refusing covet vaccine
ahead of season
they say the most popular question that
players have been asked has been
concerning their vaccination status
currently there is no mandate from the
league for the players to be vaccinated
League spokesman Mike Bass told ESPN
quote a vaccine mandate for NBA players
would need an agreement with the player
association the NBA has made these
proposals but the players union has
rejected any vaccination requirement
most NBA players are vaccinated but
stragglers remain roughly 90 of NBA
players are vaccinated as training camp
approaches according to League sources
but tensions are growing between
staffers who are vaccinated in players
who refuse them in some instances
staffers said their upset the players
aren't facing the same vaccine
requirements as most team staff and
referees in other instances staffer said
they're concerned about the health risks
of being exposed to unvaccinated players
two of the League's biggest stars
Bradley Beal and Kyrie Irving both said
they were not vaccinated during their
team's media day and I just gotta say
guys you need to stop fighting this us
rich people are exempt from all of this
NBA stars famous podcast hosts yo you go
look at the Met Gala just accept your
fate you know AOC doesn't got to wear a
mask all of the serpents do all right
this this is the direction that we're
I'm kidding by the way but this I'm
happy it's true though like NBA players
are like we're not going to do it
meanwhile the support staff are being
forced to do it yeah it's one of the
more interesting stories and uh you know
I don't see any National Guard coming in
to replace Kyrie Irving that could
average 25 points and eight assists a
game
um but it's really interesting with the
NBA because
um it actually first started off with
you know for folks who who don't know
like LeBron James has massive power over
the league it's almost like whatever he
said kind of sways and he actually uh
came out and like didn't want to get the
facts I think he just got vaccinated but
he didn't want to get the vaccine and
then it kind of forced The Players
Association to say you know what no
mandate so it's it's really interesting
to see and especially the the star
players speak out it's like a Bradley
Beal a Kyrie Irving who who hold a lot
of weight that's going to be interesting
to see Andrew Wiggins who is the uh
um shooting guard for the watch uh for
the Warriors in um in Oakland he applied
for the religious religious exemption
and got it denied so now he could only
play away games I'm really curious just
to see how that's gonna turn out only
away games what's interesting the
difference between the NFL and the NBA
right because like in the NBA you have
five guys can win you a championship for
the most part I mean you do you do have
a bench but it's five guys but the NFL
you need 12. so so the the star power is
much greater in the NBA one individual
like LeBron can command a team in the
league yeah in the NBA they need um like
they need those star players to fill
those seats like in NBA is just those
star players are more rare than the NFL
so it's really interesting to see like
the Kyrie's Bradley Bill and other other
players come out and uh and speak out
yeah because Bradley Bill just had a
media day and he said hey you know what
I already had covered I have the
antibodies he said and then he like
looked at the meeting said I assume all
you guys are vaccinated yet you could
still get it so it's like I said it's
interesting right now just with the
mandates and all this stuff and um and
then I'm curious of what's gonna happen
to Andrew Wiggins because now the owner
might be like you know what if you're
not gonna get vaccinated I can only use
you on the road I'm gonna just release
you then just pick up another guy who's
willing to uh yeah but he's going
through it right they can't just do that
yeah and he's he's a good player he's
not like he's like a guy you just kind
of like I said no National Guard is
going to come in for Andrew wiggin put
some 15 points and 10 boards a game you
know there's a lot of protests there was
a video from a couple days ago where
people in Staten Island who are
unvaccinated like starved into a mall
and were chanting the USA because
because New York has the vax Mandate but
you see little pockets here and there
you can Google it you can find the
stories of a few other people I don't
think it's enough to stop government
over you know the government's going to
mandate it people are going to follow a
suit I agree I haven't I haven't I
actually thought that like the turnouts
would be much larger we haven't seen
them now I've covered a few of these
anti-mandate protests back in California
and um one thing that I've noticed at
least from the process that I covered is
the first responder Community is really
against the mandates I'm talking about
nurses police officers
um like I said the story I think to
watch out right now is the LA County
firefighters who are now going to be
suing the county and then they are
really stepping up and saying we're not
doing this so I think um that could be a
turning point for for a lot of First
Responders depending how that uh
firefighter case goes I'm not convinced
that's going to affect the public the
way you know Kyrie Irving would you've
got the NBA and what happens if if some
owner is like I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna you know use you for these games
because you're you're refusing to get
vaccinated no they can't do it they got
star power on their hands when
celebrities like Nicki Minaj come out
all of a sudden they're fans their fans
don't care about your tribe they don't
care about science they don't care about
whatever your rules are they're just
like
big fan Nicki Minaj she said it we're
done and they'll start tweeting in
support of her love you Nikki you're the
best especially with these NBA stars now
LeBron I guess came out you know and was
praising China oh I'm sorry that was a
while ago yeah he came out and was
saying you know that he I guess he got
vaccinated and he's supportive of it so
that will have a lot of weight but I
gotta say you know when I watch some of
these viral videos I feel like regular
people are going to see this and that
those vocal uh you know people in the
NBA are of high status are gonna for one
probably a lot of people will just
blindly agree with them there's probably
a lot of people who are going to be like
I'm a big fan dude yeah whatever you say
but there's gonna be a lot of people now
who feel will feel less scared they're
going to be like if they can do it so
can I I can speak up I can stand up for
myself and it's really interesting to
see uh in in there was there were
protests to Big protests in New York
I'm surprised he protested New York over
this I mean New York is a is a Democrat
stronghold but you see New Yorkers
holding up signs I kind of feel like
the media is lying about the sentiment
on this one if the bluest place in the
country New York City I think it's the
bluest Place Maybe I'm Wrong maybe it's
San Francisco I don't know but in a
particularly Democrat place has
thousands of protesters certainly
regular people are like yo the vaccines
are great but you can't force people to
to take these things right I've had for
the last I think week when I go into
Twitter what's happening first thing
that shows up is Biden's vaccine mandate
for workers are supported by legal
precedence experts say and that same
headline and thing is keeps popping up
every day like they're trying to
convince me of it so they're obviously
it kind of supports I think it supports
what you're saying that I think that the
media is forcing The Narrative
attempting to there it that that is such
a manipulative propaganda thing because
you can argue that the legislature can
can put in rules for OSHA but not Biden
by decree so that's why why are we
getting our legal analysis from Twitter
staff you know what I mean but people
believe this stuff the problem is like
when the media does this thing they are
not exactly able to convince like normal
Schmucks who are watching TV to be like
oh now the media said it let's go and
get the vaccine it's more about like
private organizations like restaurants
and like club Owners still thinking that
oh is is this the math sentiment now we
have to mandate it I went to Brooklyn
literally this Saturday and I had to
show my vax card in one club and in
order to get into a yacht so they are
mandating it left right and center and I
think like the way the private
organizations get their information is
that they watch media and they think
that oh this is the sentiment so we need
to follow the laws and then they just
like just imply with it well that's why
it's big if the NBA stars and
celebrities are coming out and they're
speaking out against this yeah I thought
exactly I thought that Nicki Minaj thing
was that was wild huge cycle just that
Crossover with with her and Tucker is
exactly what we needed I wish I wish
dude I wish Trump was uh I wish Trump
had his Twitter because I just wanted to
see what he would even even say
like Nicki Minaj one of the greatest
rappers of all time everyone agrees is
standing up for the rights of the
working class but I was yeah I love I
love that week because I remember just
watching Tucker and he would just he
would be like crazy Nick and then he
would just bash the whole GOP he's like
why is Nikki braver than any GOP
representative of that it's true you
always have like those Republicans like
oh but she's you know pro-abortion it's
like that that doesn't matter on right
now like right now we're this is a this
is an area where you could win over a
lot of people when it comes to this this
is body autonomy win over people and uh
special you were saying hip-hop
Community like like if Nikki says
something all right and Hip-Hop is like
like you know 90 black probably like and
they will like roll with it like but you
saw people exactly pushing back Nikki
it's like hey she needs to be like shut
down now like we did it was huge I think
Jay-Z just had a a meeting with the new
mayor of New York and it was all like oh
I'm talking to her of how we could you
mean the governor yeah the the governor
and he was like oh I was talking to her
about how we could uh you know get more
of our of our people in our community
vaccinated so it's like it's big when
Nikki could come out and step out
against that narrative and then I love
that she was speaking about censorship
and then she like blasts those
journalists and like Hassan
that was the best day ever like out of
all people no my favorite thing like the
the reason why I was so much on the
Nikki train is like if you could drive
Joey uh Joy Reed crazy on MSNBC I am on
your team so I love watching
Hassan's response to Nikki was that
Tucker was a white
here's a guy who has nothing to say for
this conversation like Hassan exactly is
just like if that's if that's his hot
take for this it has nothing to do with
the issues of Liberty Liberty Freedom
medical Public Health it's just
literally like well that guy's a white
nationalist wow excellent commentary on
the issue of Hassan brilliant yeah and
then we're also seeing with uh with the
college universities it's like even with
the mandates they're still seeing covet
outbreaks like Duke Duke University had
like an outbreak of like over 300 uh
kids tested positive for covet and only
eight of those kids were unvaccinated so
even you're you're seen it in Duke
University you're seeing a lot of these
universities where like their
vaccination rate is like at 99 or you
know 98 like I was even reading uh
Harvard just went to like online classes
for three weeks and they're like their
vaccination rate is like at 97
let me let me pull this up real quick
CBS News Kareem Abdul-Jabbar says NBA
players who refuse the coveted vaccine
should be disciplined oh boy disciplined
these people are insane get in line boy
they're they're genuinely nuts yeah
Stephen A Smith too on ESPN was coming
out and saying oh you need to trade
Kyrie Irving it's like
that that's that's just the the kind of
world we're living it's like you you
like step out of the that narrative and
they they attack you it's like man it's
not even about like I said even the
places that are we're seeing the most
vaccinated rates there's still outbreaks
yeah this is what's concerning me if
that Trend continues what you're
pointing out at like in the colleges um
and that people keep getting these
breakthrough cases after vaccination
then at what point will people say stop
mandating this if it's if they're still
going to be breakouts anyway because
like like they don't mandate flu shots
you know that you can get a flu shot and
it can help you but you can still get
the flu so at what point are people
gonna I have two questions
they're they're I'm seeing all over
Twitter they're like the unvaccinated
are a threat to the vaccinated right
they're like we got to protect the
vaccinated from the unvaccinated which
makes sense and a lot a lot of people on
the left are saying like you know uh if
if we're gonna get through this and
everyone has to be vaccinated otherwise
I'll be variants and I'm like
like the flu like the flu vaccine that
nobody gets like a lot of people get it
the flu shot every year the covid-19
vaccine is the first vaccine in the
world that doesn't work unless you have
it too well no no I'm not talking about
I I understand the point they're making
there'll be variants right yeah because
it'll it'll you know Fester within
certain communities and then eventually
you can you know the the vaccine stops
working but we don't even do that for
the flu so what's different here like no
I I get I get covet is worse I get it's
like you know it's scary people can't
breathe and stuff like that but we're
not talking about Airborne Ebola is it
just like because it is novel all of a
sudden we're like this is the one where
everyone's got to get the vaccine or
what
yeah I don't know we're in some
interesting times and then we're also
seeing the put the push for the booster
shot so that like FDA just recently came
out and they didn't approve it for
everyone I think they only approved it
for 65 and older it's also also
interesting to see how the other
countries react so the president of
Mexico came out and said we are not
vaccinating anyone Under 12 years old
we're not letting big Pharma play a role
in this which I was like whoa and he's
and he's a leftist uh almost as a
leftist so he came out and spoke out
against it that's what I'm interesting
to see is there the pfizers making that
push to get like five and five to 12
year olds vaccinated which is like just
I mean they're we haven't seen any data
that they needed no risk whatsoever yeah
there's well we won't say no risk but it
is like very very very minimal yeah and
I guess the issue is they're concerned
kids will get it and then transfer it to
old people or so yeah but I gotta say
you've got
the the there's interestingly two main
camps in this there's
ant well actually at this point I don't
think it's anti-vaxx I think it's mostly
anti-mandate I think most people
actually agree this is it's fine get it
but the weird question is like why are
you making literally everyone get it it
doesn't it it doesn't make sense so like
why are they forcing everyone to do it
the big thing that they're not telling
you when Joe Biden comes out and he said
you know 98 of people got to be
vaccinated go back to normal what
they're not selling is that a large
portion of those who aren't vaccinated
live in the middle of nowhere
so it's like you can see an NBA player
and ask them like why won't you get the
vaccine and they'll say well I've had it
before I have the antibodies the
government should manate this but what
they're not showing you when they say
like you know a quarter of P Biden's
like a quarter of people haven't gotten
it it's like yeah you know like Jim Bob
who lives up on the mountain yeah who's
got no neighbors and is a homesteader is
like not gonna drive into a city to risk
himself during a pandemic just to get a
vaccine that would reduce the risk he
doesn't have because he lives in the
middle of nowhere they don't take into
consideration rural living homesteaders
Farms people who don't go into cities
and people who are talking to their
doctors and for medical reasons aren't
getting it they're just blankets saying
everyone's got to get it you know that
makes no sense why would someone who
lives in rural Wyoming be concerned
about getting sick when they don't see
anybody for six months they're probably
like I'm not even gonna see a doctor to
give me the vaccine but they include
those people in all these numbers too
yeah no like in California you know L.A
County which is one of one of the bigger
counties in the United States L.A
County's so big that like it's not just
like the city of La there's a bunch of
rural communities in LA county so it for
for us it didn't make sense to see that
you know they would like shut down all
these businesses and it affected him
even the rural communities
um you know in the middle of nowhere
like you said that they're not connected
to the city you know it's a it's like a
one-size-fit-all
um which has just been detrimental and
you know LA County 2 was the only County
out of all of the United States to make
the restaurants
um do close out their indoor and also
outdoor dining they were the only only
County that did take out only as well
and it affected the rural communities
that are not even near the city so we
got the story from the hill
Sage Steele says she only took vaccine
because of ESPN's sick and scary mandate
it's interesting ESPN anchor said she
only got it because of the Mandate which
she described as sick and scary during
an appearance on uncut with Jay Cutler
Steele told the former NFL quarterback
that she ultimately got the vaccine so
she wouldn't be removed from programming
I didn't want to do it but I work for a
company that mandates it and I had until
September 30th to get it done or I'm out
I respect everyone's decision I really
do but to mandate is sick and it's scary
to me in many ways I'm not surprised I
got to this point especially with Disney
I mean a global company like that she
added steel has previously drawn
criticism from mocking Mass mandates
responding to statistics showing more
showing that that more children have
been shot in Chicago than that of
kovachira but yes let's keep masking up
our children I'll tell you this man if I
if I still worked for Disney and they
mandated this I'd be like yay I break my
contract I am out I'll tell you
respect for speaking out because the
more higher profile people speak out
about freedom and it's not about the
vaccine I think the vaccine's Fantastic
it's about the government mandating a
medical procedure and I think what you
see here is exactly is is a really good
example of how they gain power Sage is
not worried about getting the vaccine
should not worry about side effects it's
overwhelmingly safe I think you'll see a
lot in the veres because of how many
people have gotten the vaccine I mean
you know and so she's not she's not
worried about it but now the government
is is inching us towards mandated
medical procedures I get it a vaccine is
not the most extreme of medical
procedures they're not saying they're
going to cut out you know your appendix
or anything like that
but she's she's right it's scary it's
sick now the problem I have is that as
much as she's willing to speak out
against it she's not willing to resist
it and it was interesting too Tim I
think it was a month ago the story came
out there was an ESPN
um college football reporter like field
reporter and she actually uh put out a
tweet and it went it went viral and she
said hey guys
um this day is going to be my last day I
talked to my doctor about the covid-19
vaccine and me and my family are trying
to have a second kid I just can't get it
right now and then she ended up actually
stepping stepping down and I was like
Wow and um you know you have to feel for
her because like that's her dream job
but she put her family first and she
also met with her doctor so it's like
she did all the steps that you're
supposed to do you know why she why
should she uh she should be punished for
just she met with her doctor they you
know the best decision for her and her
family for her to have a second child
was just to not get it this time and
then yeah she had she had to step down
before that September 30th deadline I
mean I'm surprised his Sage didn't step
down is your career really worth that
much she has a platform where she could
go independent she would have got a ton
of support too from from people but
after that tweet yeah she conformed yeah
it's a bummer imagine if she she bailed
out and said okay I guess I'm getting
fired start a podcast
yeah definitely instantly but I but you
know what ESPN probably pays her a lot
more than she'd start with so she's
she's an anchor for ESPN she's probably
getting you know Millions you think
Millions yeah yeah ESPN Stephen A Smith
has makes more money than like Star
everyone it's not like Ace Med like
she's probably but she's high up dude
she's been in the game for for a while
even you said 250 yeah 250 a year yeah
250 000. maybe she let's let's even say
she's getting 150 yeah you leaving going
independent you're not going to get that
paycheck this month and you're crossing
your fingers versus being like well this
job's stable but you're right she's
probably I would I don't know what ESPN
pays I'd imagine like maybe half a mill
maybe 250 to 500. it's not even with the
money that it's about like that Social
Circle like then you become that one
anchor from ESPN who did not take the
vaccine and gave up ESPN you had that
one Renegade from that Social Circle you
become that person yeah but these people
are so dependent it's like yo learned
but that's it man we are we are this is
a country that was found on a very
independently minded you know
individuals
people who are like leave me alone I'll
do my thing the Gadsden flag and now
we're slowly becoming more and more
completely and utterly dependent on the
system and other people
why do they care so much about what
other people think that's the weirdest
thing to me just be like I don't care
shut up you say it doesn't mean anything
the thing which bothers me the most is
like they have all like throughout
history in the states there have always
been people who wanted other people to
conform to their rules but they're but
the Counter Culture has also existed
right in the same time and that has like
come from like the Arts and the hip-hop
people and the stuff like that and to
see all these athletes hip-hop players
uh hip-hop artists and stuff like that
also conform to to this government
mandates that's this carrier part
everyone together decided to follow this
one set of rules it's like uh it's like
you know the Raging gets the machine now
they rage for the machine on the behalf
of the machine rage on behalf of the
machine and like culture going on hand
to hand with it and like at like
fortunately or unfortunately culture
moves mountains like whether or not it's
Joe Biden saying it'll obviously matter
more if you know LeBron says it and like
that's the scarier part of me like all
these big players are saying that you
should get vaccinated good and the fact
that other people are not vaccinated is
putting your life at risk so you you
know kind of sort of like look down at
them like that's the scarier part it's
creating two different subcultures but
we already have two different
subcultures the culture wars is being
made worse worse and now it's medical
well actually I think this is impacted
by the culture War you know people
thought in a crisis America would come
together like during the culture War and
the peak and the fighting in the street
they're like man we need a shared enemy
like in Watchmen the aliens or if it's
the movie you're talking about Dr
Manhattan and then everyone's like
that's the enemy and they join forces
instead what happened was the pandemic
hit in both sides were like I'm gonna do
acts well I'm gonna do why screw you
another screaming at each other top of
their lungs that being said I love the
metric we had Dr Robert Murphy on his
Economist talking about how the economy
is not good yet for some reason and then
I point out Democrats think it's good so
that's the easiest way to put it you
know look you want to identify what the
real cult is you ever hear that riddle
where it's like uh you come across a
fork in the road and there's like you
can go left you can go right and there's
two guys AI standing on each path one
always lies one always tells the truth
how do you figure out which way is the
path to safety because you know one will
lead you to death one will lead you to
safety and then it's like you ask the
guy what the other guy would say and
then take the opposite path
so it's like I forgot where I was going
it's a great riddle but I have some
information oh uh Sage Steele as of 2019
making 400 000 a year so their net worth
is 1.5 that's a lot of money to walk
away from yeah so when they when they
when I'll tell you this man I worked for
Disney and when I tried breaking my
contract one day I woke up to forty
thousand dollars in the bank
and they were like oh it's a bonus I'm
like for what no like we're just you
know giving bonuses and I'm like uh-huh
is my contract over yet
no no joke like I went to the president
until January and I'm like this doesn't
make sense for me to be here like I
don't know what you guys are doing
you're not doing journalism you're doing
woke stuff I was like that's not what I
produce I travel around I cover
underground stuff if you want to do that
this makes sense and then they're like
look how much money we're giving you and
then one day I wake up and I get I see
money in my bank and they're like we
need to talk and I get a phone call and
they're like yeah how's the bonus and
I'm like uh bonus for what like I'm
trying to quit and you just gave me a
ton of money it was insane it's nuts
we're kind of living two in like two
different countries in the states like
um like here in DC like you know like
you still still indoors you have to wear
the mask like I'm in the gym like
working out my mass Falls like a like a
little inch below I get like yeah I get
like threatened by the gym people and
then like I was in I was in Texas and
it's like fine it's there's like no mask
anywhere it's like life is like all
normal then you go to another state and
it's like so even just seeing that
cultural or you know shift is is also
like it's crazy let's you know what
freaks me out too is these n95 masks oh
you wear one of those No One's Gonna
complain but you're not they're not
protected because you're breathing out
Complete Air there's no filtration going
out but they don't know so they don't
complain so it's like this this
perception battle that but if you're
wearing a gator they'll be like yeah I
didn't get it I didn't get that memo
though like somehow Gators like a right
wing or something I don't know oh I
don't know oh yeah you know you know
I'll put it this way I went to the bank
today and there was this dude and he's
like there's a big plastic barrier at
the bank and the guy's wearing the mask
and I'm just like
the people working
are all in bubble bubbleville literally
and everyone else is not every other
person in the building was not masked or
doing anything and I'm just like this is
weird it's weird because you know I'll
put it this way last year they said 15
days right and then we were like okay
and then it turned and that's what you
know 18 months or whatever well the
lockdowns mostly ended you know over the
summer
or the end of spring and summer and then
they said you know okay we're gonna do
masks you know and then it was like ah
it's no big deal if you want to go to
the store you put the mask and you take
it off when you walk out but now they're
like hardcore while everyone's working
when you're going when you're outside in
between sips getting crazier and then
people were saying at the time they were
like if they mandate this it's only a
matter of time before they mandate
vaccines people were like no that's
never gonna happen then they said if you
want to take the mask off just get your
vaccine you know Gotta Wear the Mask
anymore then everyone had to wear the
mask again we literally went from hey
everybody get the vaccine and we're back
to normal to me going to the bank and
seeing a guy behind a big plastic
barrier with a face mask on when
everyone there is vaccinated and I'm
just like
there is no point where I would believe
this stops like we had the modernist CEO
like I said maybe next year Australia is
building more camps Australia's Got
Another campsite to open mid-2022
they're building camps like crazy they
don't expect this to end ever New Normal
they call it yeah CNN has that one like
doctor correspondent person and she's
always like oh um it's not your it's not
in your it's not in your like
constitution on your right so like fly
and stuff so she's you know she was
making the argument that you need the
you need the vaccine to fly but the
funniest thing is just seeing the the
experts continue to flip-flop before the
pandemic there's those interviews of
fauci coming on and saying like oh you
don't even need the mask yeah then you
need the mask then he's like you know
after you get vaccinated you don't need
it to wear outside now you do it's just
the the constant flip-flop is like how
do we continue to trust these people
what's after what's after vaccine
mandate
the Airlines and I think that's gonna be
digital passports
you know what gets me is is that the f I
don't consider the pharmaceutical
industry part of the medical industry I
think of it as like a you know it's a
foreign
medicine I mean it's definitely medicine
what they're making but doctors are it
should be decentralized doctors is like
what we've built you know
our modern system on it it just blows my
mind that a pharmaceutical company could
be commanding this at such speed they're
going to come you have they're going to
come for the doctor soon because you
could just see it like like for instance
like that that doctor that spoke to that
college um football reporter for ESPN
pretty sure down the line they're gonna
they're gonna come after him because
we've even saw it in California even
this is before the pandemic this was
like two or three years ago a lot of the
parents were protesting this new bill
where um they were going to limit the
religious exemptions on the vaccines for
kids and they they hammered on the
doctor so they so before that the
doctors didn't have a limit on the
religious exemptions they could give for
for children on the vaccines then the
the state came in and said you're only
allowed to do five per year and I think
that's what little by little they're
gonna start moving on on the doctors and
basically kind of force them to say just
tell everyone you have to get it well
they're already moving on nurses we got
the story from timcast.com North
Carolina Hospital Network fires 175 plus
workers for defying covet vaccine
mandate wow they say initially 375
employees were temporarily suspended for
refusing the injections but 200 quote
came into compliance of course and
received a medication the lineup
employees have a five-day window to get
the vaccine novent employees were given
until September 15th to get the shot
report reports WL and S workers who have
started a two-dose vaccine series will
have until October 15th of the second
dose to enter and remain in compliance
the health system said novent workers
who have been granted a medical or
religious exemption are required to
undergo weekly coveted testing where n95
masks and eye protection while at work
all right this this is weird to me it's
my question
why are there so many uh anti-vaxx
nurses nurses I was this and I'm saying
anti-backs on purpose okay thanks yeah
because I want to call them anti-mandate
humans yeah I mean but the point is if
the argument from the left is like the
mandates you should get the vaccine
what's the problem the perception of
these doctors is they these nurses they
don't want to get vaccinated why not
what about these medical employees
are why why are they saying no to this
is it really just like I believe the
vaccine is safe but you can't make me do
it I mean I I interviewed some of the
nurses that attended some of these anti
like mandate protests and from what I
got was hey we were on the front lines
of coven the majority of the nurses got
it I already have the antibodies they
don't see a reason for it so it's just
interesting to see the uh we're all in
this together and you're the front line
Heroes and to now they're they're making
an escape the fact that they are part of
this quote-unquote system like the
medical system and like the fact that
they don't have faith in this vaccine
which is supposed to be the be-all
end-all that's eye-opening and the
second thing about it is like we all
remember the time when like the culture
and the media together were like not
just other Heroes Frontline workers
which is true by the way and now they
are like you know kind of like turning
on them once some of them decide to fall
out of line yeah I mean I think
situations like this are going to wake
up more nurses and uh I mean can you I
mean just imagine that you know they've
been going a whole year telling them
that they're the Frontline Heroes we're
all in this together then a couple
months later just you know gonna fire
them and leave them on the street all
these working all those 170 people are
working class yeah uh people would take
yeah we're just gonna leave them off on
the street yeah can I just clarify you
said they're gonna slap n95 masks on the
healthcare workers those with religious
or medical exemptions so those things
don't protect outgoing air they do not
filter outgoing air and 95 masks so what
the heck are they doing
virtual signaling yeah
when they said when when you know Biden
came out and said either you get the vax
or you get tested weekly that's what
they're doing for the OSHA thing and
then the leftists were like well you
don't got to get vaccinated you should
get a weekly test and I'm like can
people who are vaccinated still get sick
yeah but it's rare okay so yes can they
still spread covet yes at basically the
same rate as those anyone who has covids
but keeping in mind they're less likely
to get it and I'm like
shouldn't you then test everybody
shouldn't the vaccinated be tested if
that's the case well now we're seeing
that I think ASU announced it doesn't
matter if you're vaccinated yeah tests
yes we got this too part of the story
The confusing surrounding so the
confusion surrounding covid spilled over
into the country's college system this
month Penn State University suspended
117 students after the co-eds missed
their mandatory coveted tests
students at University parkour are
subject to required weekly covid-19
testing and who have missed at least
three weeks of testing have been
notified by Penn State they are out of
compliance the University's health and
safety policies and have been placed on
interim suspension through the office of
student council to date 117 students at
University Park have been placed on
interim suspension for their failure to
comply to properly comply with Penn
State's weekly covid-19 testing
requirement you know those students are
based no but think about it they're like
either you get vaccinated or you do
weekly tests then people are like okay
so they get vaccinated then ASU and
other colleges are like no you got to do
a legal test anyway in some colleges
what they're doing is on the weekly test
for the students who are unvaccinated
they're making the students pay for it
every single week so they're like okay
you know we're not going to force you
but we're gonna you know we're gonna hit
you financially every single week what
happens if they like decide to like just
like not take these tests anyway do you
have do they get like forced out of
college yeah they're going to kick them
out so like now your degree depends on
it literally now whether the fact you
know what man we're we're we're at a
point where too many people are just
permanent children
so they're permanent children these
people these colleges these people at
these jobs
um you know Sage Steel much all due
respect for speaking out still a child a
child who says I cannot survive without
the nanny State you know providing that
teat to suckle dude
figure it out oh no but I need a degree
no you don't
figure out how to survive stop being so
dependent and greedy there's a lot of
people I'm not speaking for families I
understand families have bigger issues
but if you're if you're going to college
yo there's a million and one ways to
survive in this world and make a living
you don't need college but what about my
dreams I want to do this yeah well then
make then make your decision what's more
important the job or your principles for
all the people that are like I haven't
done any I don't care what the
government mandates mandates I do I'll
do it anyway it's no big deal for me
there they're not violating any of their
personal tenants they're going to go to
college they're going to get a job and
they're happy with it but if you're
someone who's going to come out and be
like I oppose this
but I'd rather have the degree then I
don't believe you that you actually
oppose it maybe just it's a it's a mild
inconvenience for you or you just virtue
signaling if you really cared and said I
oppose it I ain't going anywhere near it
yo this is your body or your child's
body that's the craziest thing to me
that people are like like Sage Steele
can be like this is sick and this is and
scary but I don't mind if someone
injects me with something I'm like then
do you really feel that way or like
what's the point of what you're saying
if you really felt that way you feel
like I ain't gonna do it yeah that's how
I'm I'm already in that boat like if
they if they do the mandatory vaccine
for the uh for the for the flights for
the airplanes I'm about to jump on that
horse man it's 19 1800 style and take it
back to Wild Wild West it's way easier
than that you just get a private plane
yeah oh yeah
the ones waiting for you outside okay
that's what's gonna happen the beanie
plane you know that you guys want to
know a secret you know rich people don't
need passports right oh you think I'm
playing you think I'm playing no no no
legit so you know some I I know some
people friends of my friends
particularly wealthy they hop on a
private plane all they got to do is say
like this is so-and-so when we're flying
in they're flying to a European airport
nobody checks them or they get special
acts as they land and nobody cares you
know these are these are billionaires
like like anyone's gonna stand in their
way this this whole like two different
classes this visual was like so obvious
during the med Galaxy which it brought
up in the beginning like oh yeah it
looked so crazy right like Hunger Games
literally like they were dressed Fancy
no masks they will look all like clean
Heidi and back in the line and they were
like these poor like I don't know what
they call like drape holders or whatever
they probably get paid like 10 bucks an
hour yeah but he's like that guy
carrying aoc's dress oh that was the
cringes it's like the lack of
self-awareness it was like so like crazy
to me like you guys see what people are
looking at right now like those people
they're all like messed up and like
standing all shy and called up in the
back while you all Rush fancy yeah there
was also a dinner too like uh Nancy
Pelosi had a dinner in California with
like some politicians and some lobbyists
and like all the workers are Hispanic
and they're wearing like the mask
attending to them and they're just these
rich little like oh yes
I think about this though think about
what what's being built when you have
the servants walking in wearing masks
and the elites no rules I'll tell you it
was I've been to a bunch of events for
like you know like celebrity events and
like you know expensive dinners and it
always was really weird to me when it's
like all of these people are standing
around and they're like you know eating
and drinking and then the servant staff
comes out and they're like serving you
food and I'm just thinking to myself
like I was at a Google event one
supervip like high profile YouTuber
thing a few like several years ago maybe
like six years ago
and I'm like I wonder what these people
are thinking you know like these these
weight staff that are there wearing
these weird little uniforms carrying you
food and just walking around well all of
the elites and you know privileged and
you know higher-ups are laughing and
partying and you're there serving these
millionaires like I would never do that
I wouldn't I would never do that when I
was growing up I snuck into those events
you know I would sneak backstage and be
like I'm here for the show you know I'm
not here to to you know serve anybody
and now it's even crazier that
it's it's almost like
don't look me in the eyes when you're
serving me wear your mask don't you dare
speak what did someone say like in The
Hunger Games book there were people
servants called avox and the and the
capital Elites like they had their their
tongues cut out yeah so they couldn't
talk so they wouldn't talk to the
capital Elites and now you have these
people wearing masks walking up
I kind of feel like that would be fun a
fun event to do be like
just do it in New York
and if you're a performer you're exempt
from the Mandate right so I could put on
an event and as the performer be totally
exempt from having to do this and then I
would put the rules in place for all of
the staff all the people who live in New
York I would just be so disparaging I'd
be like you are you are utter scum if
you're working this event you are
disgusting keep your head down at all
times don't look any of my guests in the
eyes you play grat and then you know
it'd be really funny because then we'll
get like a bunch of performers to all
just like be overtly snooty with their
pinkies out in Champaign pointing and
laughing and big look at the stupid
Parts they voted for this oh my gosh
we're rich we don't have to do anything
we flew on a private plane you think we
have to abide by those rules see no one
said it to these people in these in
their faces AOC can go to this event and
be like I'm there for cultural
enrichment no mask having some guy in a
mask have to walk behind her carrying
her dress where's the wake-up call for
these people who keep supporting this
crap maybe they need someone to laugh in
their faces and say you you love it you
know you do you sadistic masochist you
love that the rich wealthy Elites can do
whatever they want and you will just sit
there and take it
we need to see the revolution man of the
working class yeah they're asleep right
now maybe maybe I really should put on
an event you know what maybe maybe Joe
can do this Rogan when he goes onto the
Madison Square Garden because they got
vaccinated I I call these businesses in
New York and I'm like you're enforcing
this they're all like yes we are no
medical exemptions you know maybe I
should just book a venue in New York and
then just take all the time on stage to
Mock and belittle The Establishment I'll
be like look at you guys you guys are
losers
pathetic you wish you were Rich yeah but
we we don't have to abide by any rules
look at me on stage I can do whatever I
want and you can't do anything about it
when I leave I'm gonna be getting on a
private plane where I don't got to
follow any mandates or any mass or
anything because that's what it means to
be rich not like you you poor little
plague rat with your garbage
establishment follow the rules for the
Edict of the mayor someone needs to say
to their faces maybe get them riled up
so they can start saying I demand my
freedom and don't disrespect me America
used to be the country where you could
be a a piss poor drunk in the gutter and
see the mayor walk by back screw you
mayor I don't give a damn and we had
free speech now's the point now we're
now we're a nation where the people are
like what the mayor said I have to do it
oh poor baby the mayor said so I guess
then you have to just do it and so long
you mentioned this earlier so long as
everyone feels that the public demands
it they just do it what happened to the
Americans who were like get off my
property
I guess they don't live in cities I I
think that we do need an event like that
Tim I think you need to put that on
because that's the subtext when you look
at the pictures from the Met Gala that
is the subtext and that is what they're
telling you they're telling you that if
you don't make as much money as AOC if
you don't have as many Twitter followers
as some of those people you deserve to
wear a mask and they don't have to
because they're just better than you but
no one gets it through their head no one
thinks about it that hard they just take
it for granted they're like oh this is
fine that's the way things are no I just
got I got a question right the the
people who came to the Met Gala New York
City is under a mask mandate yep how
come AOC wasn't obligated to uh uh I'm
sorry I'm sorry I was wrong it's a
vaccine mandate vaccine mandated not the
mask mandate no okay so I was wrong on
that one okay but they they all were
vaccinated so I'll walk that one back
yeah so either way but the exemption
they had were like you know they were
posing for the camera and then you got
to show off yourself so I guess like you
don't have to like you know Follow The
Mask right but at the same time like
people back holding your drapes have to
maybe maybe what needs to happen is we
need to take it one step further and
like put on an event
where we not only insist that everybody
wear a mask but they should also wear
like a red dress
you know they should all be wearing it
should all be women they should all be
wearing red dresses they should like
handmaids hands me too yeah yeah yeah
and then be like what's what's wrong
it's a beautiful red dress wear your
mask and don't look me in the eyes call
it an interactive art piece and then you
just belittle them for an hour and at
the end be real nice and shake hands
when you're done and be like I was all
an act but they won't know that they
won't know that you live here you voted
for this you can leave New York at any
time you love it you know it each and
every one of those people they that's
avant-garde they want to be to have the
boot on their neck from people like de
Blasio because if at any point they
didn't you can walk right out of that
City
so why don't they
poverty well actually maybe you can't
walk out there's no walking bridge that
brings you to Jersey New York no you
gotta drive through those Josie drivers
yeah right you got the time you got to
face it yeah there's no walking tunnels
or Bridges to get out of that place huh
take a Subway you can take the PATH
train to get out of New York just swim
out of there you go so at the worst case
scenario is you put on the mask
you go on the PATH train and then you're
out you're free and then you start
walking but people want to be there you
know I'll put it this way a lot of
people are like I can't move I don't
have the money to do it and I'm like
what what you're really saying is with
all due respect the comfort of your
apartment the job you have in New York
is more valuable to you
than risking it for your freedom
for me I feel the opposite I had an
apartment in Chicago
nice up and left
got a ride share to California and had
no plans I was like because my freedom
life exploration adventure Discovery was
more important to me than stability
so for most of these people they're like
I'd rather be safe than free not me and
that's the thing America used to be a
country of I'd rather be free than safe
but now it's you know too many I guess
the cities are almost entirely safe over
free yeah I was I was pretty shocked
because in the beginning of the year I
was spending some time in California
just interviewing uh you know parents
who are having struggles with their with
their children with with the mental
health and kind of what you were saying
too Tim is like when I would speak to
his parents they were like hey my kids
mental health is so important to me like
I'm literally selling my house now or
going to Utah we're going to another
state and I remember too when we were
interviewing you know those kids in
documentary thing I mean all these kids
couldn't play in sports they were you
know shut down lockdown yet you turn on
the TV and the Dodgers were on you know
Tom Brady was winning the Super Bowl and
that's what pissed off a lot of those
like parents but I've met a lot of those
parents I said I'm done with California
we're selling this house my care my kids
happiness is way more important than
this and then I would follow up like hey
how's you know how's your first month in
Utah they're like it's everything our
kids are smiling again they're playing
you know we we got our life back yeah
again like so like it's going back to
our previous topic it's like two
different like countries right so if you
you know if you desire safety and that
bubble you know live in California if
you desire Freedom go to Utah I guess so
like that's the whole thing like whether
like whatever you choose
there's a place for it right like there
was this uh there's a writer his name is
Alec uh mcmillis and he actually did a
great article where he compared the
state of Texas and New Mexico and he
looked at the kids who played football
so in Texas they were wide open playing
football in New Mexico they were
completely shut down and the suicide
rates of those kids skyrocketed
um just and he said this is just
comparing like those just though just
those two states and seeing the amount
of kids in New Mexico that ended up you
know killing themselves and you know
during during the lockdowns and he
really did a great piece of just
analyzing both kids on each side and I'm
talking about kids that were like you
know you could be living in New Mexico
like bordering Texas and you were
completely shut down yet like 12 miles
away from you they're playing football
on Friday nights they have that normal
life and he just kind of did a
comparison and it was something I've
never seen before I think in Las Vegas
they had a Clark County they had so much
they had so many suicides from the
students that the like the
superintendent came out and said we have
to reopen immediately it's an emergency
and you know we need to bring those
conversations back and saying you know
the mental health impact act
um on these kids like it's like
everything it was like a literal single
Dimension analysis like hey this is life
saved was this life's not safe that's
all we care about and that's the only
rule we need to own that's the only
barometer which matters here like
nothing else matters it doesn't matter
if you lose your job it doesn't matter
if your kids mental health is down in
the gutter it doesn't matter if you're a
single family single single income
family none of those factors matters the
only factors matters is whether or not
that total number of Life saves was this
life not safe like that's not a way you
run things let alone make policies based
on it yeah I think there was another
great reporter Lucas uh Thomas and he
put out like the stat of like in the
military it was like military members
that died of kova 19 it was like very
low it's like 20 30 and it was like
military members in the same period that
died on suicide it was like 500 600 and
just making those comparisons kind of
like what probably still was say still
was doing was the comparison with the
Chicago kids in the in in the in the
covet it was
yeah I mean like and they don't talk
about obesity either oh yeah
30.2 of hospitalizations are obese
related just in general okay according
to the CDC yeah it's funny because you
you know you could watch the CNN and
they'll be like oh we're all about
health and get vaccinated and their
commercials are like shoving pain pills
down your throat and all these things
yeah sugar now take this high blood
pressure medicine to counteract yeah
it'll be a commercial like take this
pain pill then like the next commercial
would be like did you take that pain
pill and you were getting these side
effects call this number yeah think
about a fast food meal for just one
second
you got a burger
fries and enough sodium to give you you
know probably 200 to 300 your daily
sodium intake lots of fats and sugars
and salt so what do you drown it out
with caffeine you get a big psychoactive
stimulant along with your depressing
meal to balance it out because you're
eating all this garbage that makes you
go yeah so what do you got to do
psychoactive stimulant picks you right
back up man cycle talk about just
burning yourself out with garbage I
always thought that was funny
you know that that we have soda
everywhere and like a lot of sodas have
caffeine in it and I'm like it says a
lot about our diet
we feel bad we're sluggish and unhealthy
so we we just we have a legal
psychoactive stimulant in all of these
drinks caffeine you can buy caffeine
pills and caffeine gum like yeah there's
something wrong with us if you got to be
doing that maybe you need to be
exercising or doing something I don't
know yeah like the CDC or no Health
director ever came out and said hey guys
we are the fattest country in the world
this is what or this is what you could
do yeah this is not the fattest country
I'm pretty sure Lebanon is well we're up
there we're up there yeah they do have
really good food though but they never
they never just but they never just came
out and said hey guys something that
could probably help is just you know 30
minutes of exercise a day get you know
get some sun in you oh no no yeah they
kept they kept all that info on like on
the down low
um yeah they should have mandated they
should have mandated uh gym memberships
or something I don't know nauru Cook
Islands Palau Marshall Islands tuvalu
new Tonga Samoa we're doing pretty good
we're number 12. Coca-Cola got in there
in uh in Chile they used to be in 20
years ago they were like living life
yeah they should have mandated they
should have mandate like every American
to watch uh the Arnold documentary iron
pump and go get motivated go ahead yeah
let's let's jump to this border stuff
this story is um the sub out of the
story made me laugh from Fox News Texas
border patrol agents discover stash
houses packed with nearly 100 illegal
immigrants but wait none of the
apprehended migrants were wearing
personal protective equipment
good job Fox News so have you seen that
that's not the Babylon B it's Fox News
is what it says
they I don't I don't know uh why they
brought that up uh CBP said none of the
migrants had been wearing PPE oh my
agents provided them PPE and they were
medically screened before being
processed how yeah you think this was
available on BCP has not said one of the
migrants that's a positive for coven 19.
so
the story here should be that they found
a hundred illegal immigrants in Us in
stash houses
but for some reason it's turned into
like PPE I guess
when you drive a narrative so hard you
got people distracted I mean look that
Gabby potato thing where when I when I
was out I know just I don't care
I was talking to this guy earlier and I
was like well we're doing a new show
it's like Mysteries True Crime
paranormal and he was like oh so Gabby
Patito and I was like never wait why not
I'm curious why not because for one
the story is about a missing woman
correct there are probably 300 missing
women right now with tons of news
stories
secondly
we know that she's not alive and that
means the missing women who are alive
could use some news coverage so perhaps
we can find her or them while they're
still alive
also this guy involved in the story
apparently there's evidence There Was
You Know cross-domestic dispute stuff
and I'm like okay look
by all means report the story like you
report any other story but this
obsession with it that's like people
just started pushing all these stories
Non-Stop about what's going with this
one guy and I'm like there's probably
one of these women serial killer
hitchhiker murderer kidnapper
this is a guy who's in a domestic
dispute where apparently in one video
she was like admitted to hitting him and
then he hit her and then who knows what
happened I don't know what happened I'm
not gonna pretend to know what happened
but it's just one story that they're
giving all this attention to and now
here we are talking about I don't care I
think my favorite part about that team
has seen it with like all the other
liberal media came out and was like oh
this is a missing white woman syndrome
and they're like there's we have like
every month or every day 300 indigenous
women go missing and and they don't get
the attention I'm like you're the
mainstream media you're supposed to do
that like wait a minute you need to have
the platform to do that and they're the
ones who don't do it like the Spider-Man
meme yeah and then Brett who works here
made a good point it was like didn't
people nearly burn down the country
because a black man was killed yeah I'm
like yeah this is just it's it's it's
the stupidest trash ever you know to a
certain degree I understand what they're
saying with missing white woman syndrome
they're wrong though because there are a
bunch of missing white women there was a
video of potato with their nipples
poking through her shirt that's why it's
a bunch of like young over sexed guys
pushing this narrative I hear what
you're saying yeah it's disgusting but
you can Google search missing women and
find a bunch of but that's why this one
got no you can find a bunch of other
attractive young women who are still
alive and missing right now with video
of your nipples poking through their
shirts yes Ian yes well that's why I'm
saying this is a stupid story because
she had some Instagram followers
to push it and then everyone else having
nothing better to do or like I guess
I'll talk about it too well one thing
they'd better do is take the spotlight
off of the Afghanistan surrender oh yeah
that was like a week after that yeah
lot of other stories I mean the Border
crisis there's always something there's
always something this is what I mean
people love it because it's there's a
lot of young men in this country and a
lot of missing relationships and you see
a hot girl on TV it's like man does that
draw people there are there are probably
hundreds of women of the same age and
same everything with videos maybe it's
like the right place at the right time
kind of thing all right so like this
one's good sure sure it went viral on
Tick Tock and then the media was like
we'll roll with this story and it was
meaningless and nonsensical so we got a
real story that I want to deviate from
where we've got stash Houses full of
illegal immigrants and so I'm like I'm
gonna talk about that I don't I'm not
going to talk about one missing person
right when there could literally I could
talk about other missing people how
about other people being smuggled by
human traffickers there you go that's
not the news you got to get a video on
them that's it man people like there's
tons of it they don't know what they see
out of sight out of them put it on Tick
Tock just go on my Twitter we got the
video yes of all the people being
smuggled yeah smoking into the country
at record numbers and some of these they
don't make the news these kids are used
so some some Smuggler will take a child
kidnap him and then they'll use it to
cross the border and say it's my child
and then as soon as I cross the border
they throw the kid and they walk away or
they'll return the kid and give it to
somebody else and this kid has no idea
what's going on it's just being used as
a trafficking tool so that bleeding
hearts can be like the poor baby we
should make sure they're unified with
their parent and you're like that's not
the kid's parent dude that's a Smuggler
trying to
claiming that kid is theirs well we
don't know that that's that that's the
problem when they talk about child
separation
they just make up oh Trump was so evil
he separated parents from their you know
from their kids
how do we know those kids are related to
those old people yeah we don't even even
last night time I was in Roman Texas and
we were documenting the uh the human
Smothers bringing in these these
nicarone migrants and there was one man
you could you could tell he had he had a
little boy with him you could tell that
he wasn't the dad he was grabbing him
rough and when we had the cameras out he
was just acting really frantic and and
nervous it's like we're watching in real
time and you know where's the media this
is a this is what we're seeing at the
board is impacting brown and black lives
um at a record record number all the all
the humans smuggling the trafficking
like I said uh July and August is the
first time in Border Patrol history that
back to back month over 200
apprehensions I mean you can only
imagine all the kids and I said we
witnessed it last night there was this
man just grabbing this kid almost like
manhandling them and I'm like
yo I mean look what's going on in Border
Patrol is like we know we know we know
what's going on um there that's not
that's not the dad um and that's
happening every single day and when
we're down there documenting the human
smoking one thing that I always come to
mind it's like this is just a little bit
part of a border that we're able to see
could you imagine the the rest of it in
Arizona to New Mexico and Texas and it's
happening every day it's become like the
new normal but we're like over that Roma
Texas they're used to having the raps
drop off kids
um sex traffic human smoke like I said
they had those those bracelets so you
could you could keep track with with the
proof of purchase and that's not making
the News That's not making uh the
headlines that should be like our our
top thing like we actually have a
humanitarian crisis at our border I
don't know if if the rest of America
just you know just because it's the
United States you know when people think
humanitarian crisis they think oh they
think Yemen or the Middle East but we
literally have one here at the southern
border and it's happening everything
it's happening right now what we're
speaking to some extent like people are
like desensitized to it like since like
it the drum was being beaten since like
20 whatever 2017 like the Force like
Trump puts kids in cages that was the
first time when people were like oh
there's an actual crisis at the bar and
then from there I was like today it's
like oh I got dropped used to get
dropped it's like it's like different
group of people back then it was Mexico
now it's like what Haitian and I was
speaking to a border patrol agent in
these uh in these border facilities
right they're they're in these rooms
what they that they call pods and these
pods they're only meant for like eight
migrants at a time yeah border patrol
agent was telling me stuffing there's
like 400 people in these eight person
pods each stacked on against each other
like 400 in each room where they're only
meant for eight like he said there are
people literally sleeping on top of each
other like he was texting me all this
all this information he's like hey with
these Haitians it's even worse and that
a lot of those Haitian males they came
with young like young children and he's
like we're we're trying to break them up
you know from the the real Falls or not
but they're like we there's so many
migrants we there's just not enough that
we could do and even even NBC News put
out a report last month that those
migrants are being sexually assaulted
um in those facilities there's no way to
keep track of them the New York Times
put out a report last month that one uh
one out of every three migrant Children
released into the United States they
lose track of Biden was smuggling kids
across the United States remember that
story nope there's a video of it and
that stuff just disappears and the funny
thing is Joe Biden's approval writing
didn't take a hit from it nope can I see
one of those wristbands well let's let's
let's let's can I have one of those are
you giving can I have one of those to
keep thanks man
this is this is it if you want to
remember I want to remember this
this is just like the reason why I kind
of collect them and kind of bring them
is just to kind of show the kind of
American audience like this is happening
in real time and they say you know on
these braces they say entregas which
means delivered and they actually treat
these migrants like almost like an
Amazon product like a shipment so two
things either happen either the markets
have already paid so they'll be you know
they'll cross and you know they'll be
releasing the United States or two as if
they didn't pay
um they're full price then they'll be
essentially become indentured servants
and slaves here
yeah then you can see like the little
kids always have these bracelets on
their ankles so they can't like easily
come off
um so it's just it's it's crazy to see
see it in in person and that it's like
it's literally happening in the United
States and one border patrol source told
me that the cartels are making up to 14
million dollars a day just off human
smoking not even counting they're where
does money come from it's the cartel
yeah well the cartoons are immigrants
have are in the cartoon no the cartels
are really smart is when they get
connected with these migrants these huge
Caravans is they all the majority of
like the central Americans they already
have family in the state so what the
cartels do is they they connect they get
connected with the family in the states
and they make them pay the five thousand
six thousand seven thousand dollars for
that fee so it's very well organized and
the people back in the States where do
they get that money from the the family
in that already lives here in the United
States oh okay yeah like so they send
their money back yeah so instance like I
was interviewing a couple Salvadorian
families that like they had to pay a
coyote like seven thousand dollars to
get like their cousins here to the board
so like the the the cartels are smart
they'll get connected with the family
members back in the U.S they'll make
them pay the fee because they have the
money and that's how they kind of
organize and get here and like I said
and if they don't pay the fee they
essentially become Adventure servants
and that's something that me and Sonic
got to see firsthand we just um you know
spent like two months in Southern
California documenting these cartels who
are coming into that area they're
starting up illegal marijuana growth so
usually when you know when people hear
illegal you know marijuana girls it's
like oh what's what's the big deal it's
just pot it's just like two hippie dudes
in the middle of nowhere listening to
reggae but what's happening is that
these cartels found out that in
California it's so rural these deserts
they start up illegal marijuana
operations and then they'll smuggle the
the migrants from South Texas and force
them to work those marijuana grows and
they'll arm them because out there
they're having literally cartel battles
between other cartels and other magic
groups me and Sonic got to um we got to
be embedded with San Bernardino County
um their marijuana enforcement team when
they when it went to raid yeah they went
to to rate a marijuana grow that was
operated by the Chinese Mafia and when
we were when we got there the the people
who were working the that girl were
Chinese uh Chinese Nationals that were
smuggling into the southern border
undocumented and they were crying when
they got arrested me these are people
who are literally working off at that
they have no idea that's their way of
paying back to the cartel members by
putting their hours in and this
marijuana grows and but the problem is
like since the cocktail knows like they
are like kind of the Kingpin so like
they are not involved in the ground to
ground so anytime raids happen the
people who get arrested are these
undocumented ligaments uh immigrants and
this is like a whole system like hey you
come into the water and if you have if
you are already paid into the system
well then good if you're not paid the
way you put work in is by basically
infiltrating these Californian deserts
and by growing marijuana and not only
that there is like cartel turf wars
between the from different cartels
because there's Mexican cuddle there's
Chinese cuddles there's Armenian cuddles
so it's like a whole racket Armenian
Chinese down there in Mexico no in
California California wow in the
California desert and we saw all trees
yeah so we were out there we um we
discovered that there's an Armenian
crime organization the Chinese Mafia
Mexican cartels are all fighting in
Southern California for these large
desert properties so when I was out in
um you know I was covering the Border
early with the crisis I met I met
Congressman Mike Garcia who represents
District district 25 in California so
for those who don't know District 25 is
a purple District meaning it could swing
Democrat it could swing Republican that
was the same thing it was it was the
district that Katie Hill had within yeah
she got caught with three seven her
staffers but what happened was is that
Mike Garcia won in that special election
by less than 500 votes and then a year
later into him you know serving for
congress he has now this cartel issue so
when I met you know Congress Mike Garcia
I was like Hey Congressman like you're
the only representative from California
like in South Texas like how come you're
out here he's like hey we have a major
Mexican cartel human trafficking human
smoking problem back in my district the
crazy thing is like
um Mark Garcia's district is where my
hometown is I was like wait back in you
know like Palmdale Valley like we have a
cartel problem he's like yeah you got to
come see it for yourself and that's when
I call outstanding I'm like you know we
need to do a full investigation find out
what's going on so we went Deep dive and
went into like the cartels the the human
smuggling we even got like a little spy
drone that we would fly over the grow
Ops and you know there's just so much
also layers to this and what kind of
really opened up the floodgates was that
in in California they passed prop 64
which legalized cannabis Statewide but
it downgraded um illegal cultivation
from a felony to a misdemeanor and now
the cartos kind of opened up this this
black market business and are just
dominating and then what helps them out
in L.A counties they have a very
Progressive D.A George cascone who I
mean doesn't even doesn't charge anyone
at all and it's just it's kind of crazy
this is all resulting from the southern
border well so so what's up with these
Chinese cartels are they like how are
they getting in what are they doing so
they're essentially the same way as the
Mexican Mexican cartels as their start
they buy property start up illegal grow
ups and they'll smuggle their own
Chinese Nationals through Mexico through
Mexico Mexico and up and up to to
California like I said I was I was
shocked we were shocked because we were
like hey these are like Mexican people
like we walked in so the sheriff was
like hey uh so we got some we have a
raid coming do you want to Shadow us and
we were like yeah let's do it and we
followed them and once we pulled up to
the to the grill we saw the girl there
was like huge huge huge marijuana plants
getting confiscated and then we saw like
four people like handcuffs on sitting
outside waiting to be like put into the
car and then we just peeked in and they
were like clearly not Hispanic and then
we were like what are the Chinese
people doing here and they were like oh
even they are smuggled through the
Mexican bar as to through the southern
border and like that's the Gateway yeah
Ed Calderon was on the show last week
and he said it's like an open joke
around the world that anyone can get
into the us through the Mexican border
they just go to Mexico and then they up
they come I mean they're right they're
right I think when P when these cartels
or these humorous mother groups look at
the what happened with the Haitians that
it almost you know we're giving them a
better argument because they're all they
can say is hey you just go up to the US
you claim you're a family unit you we
will push you in a caravan they can't
handle it so they're just literally
gonna process you really quick and
release you into the United States and
we even did interviews Tim with with
these Haitians outside the airport and I
was like hey you know were you tested
tested for covid-19 before being
released into the public nope of course
no yeah not only that they were treating
the whole system as like a win like they
were like oh we did send back the single
males but we kept the families I'm like
okay uh these families though so like
this there's no way to verify if they're
if they're family so yeah I'm mean like
I said this is all resulting from an
open board it has really a lot of
consequences even for just regular
American workers this big corporations
love the open borders because it keeps
their wages down and I mean you just get
hit all angles so yeah me and Sonic went
like I said we did a deep dive two
months into it the the documentary is
going to come out um next week so we
really hope a lot of people get you know
just look at it and just kind of see the
reality on the ground of you know people
being human smaller human traffic I
think when people think about this they
don't think that it's that could happen
on American soil at the rate it is but
it's it's happening and you know and Ed
said this on your show too uh Tim is
that people think that the Mexican
cartels are not here they're they're
here they've been here for years and now
they're getting more emboldened people
forget about the fact that people
usually
don't empathize with the topic because
they're like oh once they're here
they're here like whatever but like once
they're here they're in our communities
like I don't know what they're doing
like some of them may be like honest
workers but at times they're working for
the cartels and growing weed and you
know terrorizing neighborhoods and
deserts where there's like no cop
presence you know people don't
understand too uh I I did a story on the
drought in California several years ago
went to a bunch of farms I met um some
young kids who were born in America but
their parents were illegal immigrants
and they were working on farms you know
like picking dates or something or
whatever fruits they do and stuff down
there and they were like oh yeah you
know our parents get 14 bucks an hour
and I was like that's really interesting
you know and they were like their
parents aren't documented that's what
they said and they make 14 bucks an hour
and I'm like 14 bucks an hour like why
not just hire an American it's actually
really obvious no benefits no taxes so
if they can pay someone 14 bucks an hour
an American would have to get paid more
because of taxes on both ends the
employment tax as well as the person's
income tax so when people say things
like well they're doing the jobs
Americans wouldn't want to do I'm pretty
sure everyone's an American and said you
know 15 bucks an hour 14 bucks an hour
you know a lot of people would be like
yes please because because right now
they're the fight for 15 in New York
they got it basically but this was this
around the same time around the same
time I'm hearing that illegal immigrants
undocumented immigrants are getting 14
bucks an hour to pick fruit in the
fields Americans are are fighting for a
minimum wage at that level because
they're not making that much at
McDonald's or whatever
so basically they look at it this way
you know we're going to pay 14 bucks an
hour to this person and we're going to
save 7.5 on employment tax we're gonna
we're gonna They're Gonna Save 7.5 on
their end so we'd have to pay 15 bucks
an hour we save a little bit but we're
still paying comparable to what an
American would get so yeah Americans
would love to have that job I when I was
in LA I was working at a restaurant that
had a lot of illegal immigrants working
there and
they were the cool people but illegally
in the country and there was this like
building on the street that had all
these like apartments in it where they
stayed and it was like four illegal
immigrants and it was super cheap rent
and I wanted it it was super nice but
compared to my place but it so yeah but
this concept too like it was you know
years ago like even Bernie Sanders would
come on and said
um that he didn't support open Wars
because of the how it impacted American
wages so even you know he had a you know
he got pushed by the by the progressive
group but even even he saw and I think
just you know we got to take out the
politics and just say this is an
American thing yeah this is an American
problem that we're seeing and right now
the people who are suffering the most
and being taken advantage of are these
like legit family units or these
innocent you know people that are live
in these countries that are getting sold
this dream they're like hey you just
come to the US you gotta get temporary
protected that is the time is to come
now the Bible Administration put that
signal I remember during that campaign
Kamala Harris had that that famous quote
that went viral was like you know if you
come here and illegally we're not going
to deport you that's inhumane gonna be
the more Humane organization I mean just
that little quote you just gave the
cartels said come to the Border
the whole life surge the Border if you
want to come come give us your week
you're sick your poor wasn't at the
American thing back in the day that's
not the America of today we're
overloaded no you mean going to Ellis
Island to be processed yeah like calm
immigrants everyone that was a hundred
years ago we're not in that position now
to take all these new immigrants that
was a poem at an island where immigrants
were being processed legally of course
of course but I don't even think we can
handle I mean we can barely handle legal
immigration right now this country is
overloaded I think we fully optimize I
think we can handle legal immigration
the problem is how can you handle legal
immigration when we can't track all the
illegal immigration exactly so we're
like hey we want to allocate x amount of
space to people we've got this line of
people and then everyone just rushes in
you're like I don't know where everybody
went or what our resources are anymore
yeah and look what happened with the
Haitians 15 000 came and from Chile and
Brazil yeah then they get processed and
they got released in the United States
all in under like a week just because
the Haitians under their Bridge was
looking bad optics for the vitamination
they're like hey just hurry up speed it
up we don't even care if you test them
or not just get them get them earlier
the thing which also bothers me and this
is like a devil's advocate argument
which is like Haiti is actually a messed
up country like there's so many things
wrong with Haiti especially with the
president getting murdered and like
earthquakes and stuff like that so there
may be some people with actual Asylum
claims there so but when you overload
the system and you have been doing that
for like five six years maybe those
people like you know who are supposed to
get asylum in an ideal world are like
lost in the dust and guess what there's
even more coming there's already 10 000
stuck in tapachula Mexico there's even
thousands more making their way through
to Colombian Panama and it's not just
the Haitians it's the Venezuelans
they're still coming at a record number
Central Americans are still coming at
record number we were literally
documenting the human smoking last night
in in Roma and it's just like you know
when I when I speak to border patrol
it's like you know the the for them and
it's kind of a little bit obvious now
looking at the hindsight but it's like
just the removal of Trump's uh you know
remain in Mexico policy really just
opened up the floodgates because the
thinking was for the migration
Administration is why would I pay the
cartels and human smiling groups to
cross into the USA legally for the Trump
Administration to give me a court order
but I would have to wait in a Border
Town of Mexico which is most likely
cartel related the risk is just too high
so when the bind Administration came out
and said it's removing the remaining of
Mexico policy that literally just opened
up the floodgates was in a court
overruled that so you got a court over
rooted and said you have to do it but we
I mean for my for my reporting we
haven't seen any evidence of those uh
migrants having to wait in Mexico I mean
we just saw with the Haitians if it was
true those Haitians would have had to
stay in Surah they were going back and
forth yeah yeah there's no border yeah
it was in the I don't know if you guys
saw the video on Twitter I was in the
water when they were transporting
supplies and I would I asked the Haitian
the Mexican said hey how come you're
standing here not going over there
they're like we were only eating like
one time a day over there so it's like
I'd rather be on the Mexican side wow
but now the Mexican authorities went to
this it was like a makeshift you know
Haitian camp and they made those
Haitians move so we're getting reports
right now there's thousands of Haitians
going to Reynoso Mexico which that means
the direct town across women is uh
McAllen Texas one of the hardest hit
sections in Texas is that RGB area man
you were saying earlier I think that um
Haitians that had moved to Haiti or that
had moved to Chile yes we're living in
Chile for a long time they've been there
now they come up here and they get
deported from the US but they get
deported to Haiti well essentially
what's happening is all these Haitians
were living in Chile had already had
chilling IDs Refugee status and things
like that then when the when we made the
transition from the Trump to the Bible
Administration the the character the
Smothers told them your time is now if
you want to make make a run to the
states so we had thousands of Haitians
come up but they got stuck in tapachula
Mexico so that's the Border Town in
South and South Mexico the government
there actually didn't let the Haitians
travel without proper documents the only
thing is is that the government never
never actually process documents so what
happened was you had thousands of
Haitians living in tapachula waiting for
something to happen like slipping on the
streets while thousands more kept coming
so so many came on the week of September
12th which is actually a Mexican holiday
called el grito the local government
gave him a three-day pass to travel and
they ended up the human smokers everyone
they moved them up to uh now is one of
the few border towns that's actually not
like controlled by a cartoon group so
meaning that's why in those videos
you're able to see the Haitians walk
that River back and forth bring supplies
because they didn't they didn't have to
pay if they did once they crossed that
one time it's done and that's when we're
with the Haitians you don't find the
wristbands at all well tell us about
pull out the wristbands and let's
actually go through it this time and
just tell us about what they are what
they mean so uh Jorge's got a bunch of
these wristbands these are human
Smugglers put these on on people I want
you to at least keep these two it's good
to see yeah it's kind of scary it's kind
of creepy yeah so these are the so this
is what um kind of our reporting has
showed is that the central Americans
have to pay a human smiling group or
cartel group to cross uh the Rio Grande
River and the different color wristbands
means there's different human smuggling
groups so here we have red ones we have
some black ones and we have some purple
ones the majority of these ones say
entregas which means delivered that
means the product has already been
delivered so either if they haven't paid
the full pavement then they become
indentured servants on our side but they
also have to pay for the kids yeah these
are it's insane to see it in person
because I mean literally like pull it
straight so people can read what it says
yeah like I mean like like literally
literally last night guys we were
interviewing migrants coming from
Nicaragua with our human smoker right in
front of us we have the video it's up on
Twitter and um we got to collect these
from the market the reason that I keep
getting asked like why do you collect
them it's like we're trying to show
these are numbered dude these are serial
numbers yeah and it's different like
it's different you know for me just
telling you like hey this is what's
going on then when you see it in person
you're like whoa wait dude this is this
is this is a mechanized industry oh
there is a serial number on these bands
yeah well well organized four thousand
one
186.48 and Ian and then like like last
night like the little kids would have
them on their on like their own and it's
just it's crazy how they treat these
people and like I said last night there
was a moment where one of the the males
from Nicaragua had his little boy and
you could just tell he was not the
father I mean he was manhandling this
kid like a product and when we when we
had the cameras filming him he was Frank
frantic trying to trying to like hide
behind a national Guardsman and the
crazy thing to Tim is being there in
person is so you know on the Mexican
side we're witnessing the raft come with
the with the kids I mean we're talking
about babies in these boats that could
drown I mean it's like one of the
saddest scenes when they get dropped off
on the American side and seen that
struggle but so what they they come from
the Mexican side on the American side is
a National Guard with flashlights
directing them to come here so then
they'll literally drop them off right in
front of the National Guard instead
sometimes the National Guard goes in the
system and then so we ask them like you
know how come you guys don't pursue the
human Smugglers according to them they
say they don't arrest the human smokers
because their worry is that when they go
to arrest them that they'll flip over
the graph so then the kids would drown
and then all the attention goes with the
kids but I I just can't believe this
like it's just happened so Brazen yeah
so so it doesn't even matter we could
have every single National Guard from
every single state be there
but it they're literally doing nothing I
mean and then they have like M16s they
don't even have they're not even loaded
dude migration has been the downfall of
a lot of Nations over the over them look
at look at Sweden right now there's
there's really massively with having all
these these huge influx that's it I
actually don't think that's true uh a
lot of the problems that Sweden's facing
has to do with 20 years ago so Somali
Somali refugees and it's not even the
refugees it's their kids who are who are
because Sweden is so overwhelmingly
racist what they did was in the 90s they
brought in a bunch of Somali refugees
those refugees then had children who are
100 Somali but born in Sweden speaking
Swedish and then because swedes are so
racist they were like we're not going to
give you jobs or education so you
basically created this you create
ghettos and then these people who are
from Sweden aren't viewed as Somali by
their you know family in Somalia and
they're not viewed as Swedish by people
in Sweden so they form pocket
communities effectively viewing
themselves outside the state so that's
that's Sweden's Sweden's issue and I I
you know of all the people to talk about
social justice or whatever now Sweden's
legit racist like they will not give you
a job if you do not conform and we we
talk to a bunch of Americans who said
the same thing so it's maybe race isn't
the rights were right where maybe
they're like they're like um homogeneous
like nationalists yeah like if you are
not discernably Swedish in accent and
color they won't hire you it becomes
very very difficult but they will create
ghetto subsidized housing I mean like
literal ghetto not you know subsidized
housing blocks where they'll put you and
then be terrified when violence breaks
out so so it is it is a bit different
you know in Sweden yeah going back to
the the Roman Empire basically part of
the downfall of that was all the mass
migration from the north because the
Huns were coming from the East and it's
just you know just spilled over and then
you'd see in Desperate Times there would
be these huge like
like civilizations would be migrating
and the Romans would go murder them all
because they couldn't they couldn't
handle it it was like if they come we
lose so they would so like this is the a
horrible dystopic future that could
happen if we don't somehow solve this yo
it's happened it's happened well we have
technology we have like long-range
communication
1.4 1.5 million apprehensions this year
not counting the people who break
through without being caught this it's
unprecedented this is you know people
are you know people say I'm Doomer I'm
black build we shouldn't be we're going
to win I'm like you didn't understand
something
we Freedom may win but not before the
system around us falls apart so where
you are things might actually start
getting I mean it's bad right now right
but I don't think the United States
survives everything that's happening
from the mandates from the from the the
breakdown between states the social
cohesion to the mass migration
it's just I don't see the Republic as it
stands surviving this now as for us as
individuals in our culture I think it's
going to be a good for a lot like Texas
is going to do better Florida will do
better West Virginia will do better New
Hampshire will do better New York and
California I suspect we'll do worse but
maybe those people enjoy it and they'll
be happy with it Tim did you see uh
Sarah Silverman come out and was like oh
we need to split split it to like USA
one and usa2 that sounds a great idea
yeah
it's like okay it's not about we need to
it's that the sentiment is there and I
think we're on that track no matter what
we want to do yeah because we have two
different populations in America it's we
have the I listened to everything the
government tells me you know we have the
hey stay stay out of our Lives we still
want to keep that old school American
style so we're seeing
um that split but what's actually also
interesting on the immigration is uh
Chile this past week was actually
holding protests against the Venezuelan
migrants that are coming into their
country so we're seeing kind of that
kind of play out in in South America as
well but as of right now we're getting
reports that more Haitians are making
the Trek to the the US Mexican border
yeah and uh well it was fun huh yeah
yeah while he's holding a literal black
pill yeah it's uh it's Ian's obsidian
Sophie Union only lasted 69 years the
United States we got you know 200 and
about 270 almost 260 something right is
that where we're at yeah and just
letting in this huge migration isn't
good I mean and then we're also seeing
with all the um kind of the Afghan
immigrants that we just we just brought
them in refugees we just brought in
there was those are there already
reports of some sexual assault in some
of the military camps that they're
staying at
we just have to vet these people I was
speaking to border patrol agent they're
saying it's impossible to vet these
markets at the at the pace that they are
it's like it takes such a long time it's
like there's no way we know anything
about these people especially the
godaways that's actually the real scary
number when you when you tell Lux so
there's a lot of stuff we talk about
when we say like the Republic is falling
or whatever Joe Biden's rule by decree
separation of powers are are completely
gone the states are so far at odds with
each other there's there's no there's no
um compromise the Democrats are like get
rid of the filibuster and RAM through
our agenda in the face of Republicans
instead of just take care of your own
States why should New York Ram through
an agenda for West Virginia makes no
sense but what are we hearing in
response in response conservatives being
like if we get the house back we're
going to impeach Biden and you know I
respect that they should but they're
like you know we'll get rid of the
filibuster then we'll Ram through stuff
and it's like bro the only track we're
on is it breaks apart but when you
mention the National Guard is just
Fanning these people in and being like
well there's not much we can do it's
like dude when your border can't guard
its border and people can walk back and
forth for takeout you have no border and
if you have no border you have no
country it's it's honestly it's a joke
to have these how you know just watching
like them go back and forth then you
know seeing the National Guard
I'm like what are we doing to it and
there's like literally no no enforcement
and the cartels continue to win The
Establishment politicians that push
these policies continue to win and I
just don't know how how long we could
sustain this I think we're on Pace right
now for two um like two million
apprehensions that the U.S selling
border still not counting uh those those
gotaways that get in we have these large
family units that we don't know if
they're family units getting processed
into United States getting flown all
over the country I just flew to today
from uh from the McAllen Airport to
Dallas and then on my flight I mean it
was the majority were Central American
migrants
holding with the folders that say I
don't speak any English can you help me
with my next flight and and then and
then on the other side it has all the um
all the like where they're stopping so
say like McAllen to Houston to New York
or New McAllen Houston to New Jersey
whatever so they're being flown all over
so are the Haitians like I said the
majority of Haitians that I interviewed
are going to Florida but still they're
they're getting flown all over and
there's no track
um there's no way to track these
migrants and another thing is there's no
way to make sure that they even go to
that court order I was speaking of
border patrol sources I say only 13 of
the time they even go to that to their
court order so it's they they already
said we essentially just already let
them loose and then when you speak to
that she's like hey are you going to go
to your quarter they're like what I live
here now so they look at me like I'm
like I'm crazy though so that's the
that's the situation that uh we have a
hand and supposedly we're still going
through a pandemic yet we're releasing
thousands of folks uh we're not tested
for cover 19.
who was it uh Peter Ducey is that his
name the journalist yeah yeah he asks uh
Saki are you testing these people for
covet when they cross the border and
she's like no yeah she's like she's like
oh we're not testing because they don't
plan to stay here alone
um like well that's the office yeah I'm
like that's the opposite we're seeing on
the ground the thing is when they get a
court order these migrants that court
order could take up to even three years
for you for them even to have a date
what is the red bracelet
these are just like I said yeah it's
like every every color is a different
migraine or smuggling group so last last
night we were running into the same
group with with all these uh with all
these black black bracelets and the
majority of the migrants that we spoke
to last night were coming from Nicaragua
we did meet two from Cuba which I was
pretty pretty shocked but every time
that we're down there we want to show
these people that or show the American
audience like look what's going on at an
alarming rate and the thing is it's like
the the national attention from the
border it like the spotlight moved as
soon as the Haitians got cleared out of
the bridge like we were there all the
mainstream media left and they were done
in I was like you know what let's let's
continue to to show people what you know
what's going on and I'll be back I'll be
back in Texas pretty soon but
this situation like I said it rolls out
not just you know Texas but like how you
know Sonic and I'm being in California
seeing those migrants being forced to
work out those grow-ups and it's
happened all across California in
different states as well you you were
saying in like in ancient Rome they were
dealing with a migration crisis yeah the
Huns came from the East and tons of
civilizations fled into like Northeast
Rome is that basically the fall of the
Empire is a big part of it there was
also I wasn't like a credit crunch
um I don't know I know in Greece there
was I don't know if the endangered Rome
there was it does feel though like China
is laughing at us seeing this huge
demise and
kind of everything you were saying to
Tim with like the state powers and stuff
but it's also that our Elites in this
country are not even loyal to this
country they have already aligned
themselves with with China whether it's
big business whether it's entertainers
or politicians they've all decided that
they've aligned themselves with you know
maybe maybe 2008 was the iceberg and
since then the elites have been like
well
we got 20 years start collecting that
silverware to sell off and they hit up
China and say look our ship's sinking we
want to place you want we want a safe
landing so we'll give you all the good
Fine China from the boat
that's what we're facing look at uh the
whole situation with uh with a John Cena
you know he came out and said something
about positive or I think he like
recognized Taiwan and then within two
days he's already making his video in
Mandarin apologizing to the Chinese
people but that's so that's that's all
the American companies do the same thing
is they they'll bow down their head to
China That's why um that's why I love
South Park when they continue to troll
China and and Jing and stuff like that
but yeah I mean like I said our Elites
our politicians have all aligned uh with
with them and you know they're not loyal
to this country I mean we we've already
been seeing this you know in the NAFTA
and the trade deals when we shipped all
of our uh manufacturing jobs to China
and you know we saw States like Michigan
and Ohio Penn State I mean uh and
Pennsylvania lose all that manufacturing
jobs and we saw all those basically you
know huge unemployment in men that you
know we're used to you know I'm talking
about like single income family men now
have no have no jobs because admit the
those manufacturing jobs got shipped
either now we're seeing on the southern
border all the Fentanyl and opioids
getting pushed into those same
communities
it's a bit apocalyptic I guess I think
in the long run I mean humanity is going
to be fine but for a lot of people I
think they view America as the world
and so what I see it is like you know
look if in the end West Virginia Texas
New Hampshire or Florida Wyoming
whatever red state says we're gonna do
our own thing
is that really the end of the world is
it really bad
I don't know no definitely not took a
look at the sea people is another group
of migrants 1200 BC or something that
came from the north and no one knows why
but they overran Mesopotamian it was the
end of like Civilization as it was known
and then like small Dark Age and then
you start to see like the Resurgence but
that's just the nature of reality is is
tragedy and migration I don't know we
have great technology you know
long-range electricity well long-range
communication electricity so maybe maybe
we can use the American ideals and
rewrite like a a more organized system
for the globe I think it's beyond
nationalism at this point obviously
these borders don't really matter
anymore but it's also like a huge it's a
huge cultural problem because these
people are not going to assimilate and
if they're working low you know low wage
low-skill jobs they're most likely going
to get on some type of welfare that then
after that the American taxpayer has to
pick up that bill not only that like
let's say if someone's whole ideology is
not aligned towards you know protecting
my protecting what America is based on
and stuff like that and like they go
towards empathizing more with these
migrants so like think about like I
would appeal to them like think about
what they have to go through right
because like when we were talking to all
these people in the deserts they were
like we watched these people run these
marijuana camps all these illegal
immigrants they do not look happy they
have to work in like 100 degrees out in
the open running these platforms being
forced to do so if they don't abide by
these rules will kill them so if you are
like just like as like let's say you're
like a full-on progressive and you're
all about immigration and all about
letting people in like just think about
what conditions these people have to go
through with the fact that Sonic they
don't because this is impacting black
and brown people at a record number and
they're nowhere to be found not not one
Progressive has even came down to the
border and says look at these conditions
look at these uh facilities that are
that are overpopulated by over 500 some
of these like I said some of these pods
are only made for eight people they got
400 people in there even NBC News is
reported that they're getting sexually
assaulted where is that outrage only
when they need votes they'll come
they'll they come speak up but that's it
yeah otherwise it's a conspiracy like
look at the photos and like they came
from like the Haiti situation like those
photos were like horrible oh yeah like
if like let's say you have like no
empathy whatsoever to like like the
American ideal and protecting populism
and all that stuff like just empathize
with these people like this whole
situation at the end of the day was
created by uh these policies and these
attracted these people and they were
like All-Star yeah and let's say a
little exploitive like let's take
advantage of it and now they're going
through this whole mess like as of super
Progressive person like I'm pretty sure
this is not what you wanted to see all
these people like go through all this
mess yeah I'm interested now in the the
2024 race because immigration is going
to become again a top issue a lot of
democratic voters that I'm speaking to
every day the immigration issue is
getting them to switch they said okay
hold on and that's why Biden's approval
rating just kept dipping and then we
were speaking to someone DHA sources who
they told us the Bible Administration
was taking such a political blowback on
the Haitian migration they said by
Friday those those all those Haitian
markets need to be off the bridge in
Port Adventure open we're going to act
like nothing ever happened so I don't
think Democrats can survive politically
no this is a huge blowback I mean you
got a year basically an eternity so
we'll see what happens but Biden's
approval ratings in the gutter the
honeymoon period's over people are
starting to wake up to the fact that
this guy's out of his Gore and he can't
run or manage anything I think Joe
Biden's presidency was literally a steal
all the silverware before the the people
find out what your your plan is so it's
like South Park remember that South Park
episode from 2000 I think it was 2008
Obama and McCain run for president and
the real the real point was a was a
heist they needed to get access to the
White House so it was like he was like
Ocean's 11 or whatever yeah it was like
three I was like whoa that's what it is
Joe Biden was like I'll get PR once I
become president I can extract as as
much as I can from the system before it
implodes and Kamala Harris has also
taken a huge hit on her popularity
because she basically got assigned
borders and she's been taking a hit and
according to like like the some of these
White House sources who have came out of
our talk and they're saying come on here
doesn't want to visit the Border because
she doesn't even want to take the blame
anymore and she kind of felt like they
put her in that position but she's she's
taken a huge hit Biden is taking a huge
hit because on this one issue you could
get those Latino Democratic voters to
say hold on this is our people now I'm
not voting for this again so we'll see
and then all those um you know in the
data back setup because if you look at
the Texas border towns they're all 80
majority Latino in 2016 all those border
towns voted overwhelmingly for Clinton I
mean they're Democrat even 2020 Trump
won all those counties by the border and
if you're seeing those uh working class
Latinos finally say this is enough is
enough it's impacting our local
communities I just entered I put up the
video out on Twitter where I interviewed
Latino working class in Del Rio and they
were just livid at the Haitian migration
situation I mean that was funny I was
speaking one resident whose brother is a
veteran he said that when he his brother
needed to go to the hospital they were
full of migrants they could not help him
out next year is going to shock I I
think it's it's fair to say if if the
trends continue with the border of Texas
oh with Miami a blue District going red
I mean Democrats might be shocked
historically a president doing this bad
should lose 30 to 50 seats the Border
wasn't even this bad under Obama I mean
and the thing is when we were covering
the Border crisis in the beginning I
kept thinking oh it can't get worse than
this even it the numbers continue to get
worse like I said July and August first
back to back months over 200 000
apprehensions we're already over 1
million if I think by the same rate last
year we're already at a five percent
increase I mean 500 increase in
apprehensions this is nothing like we've
ever seen before I speak to border
patrol they're overwhelmed and now
they're also they also not only are they
overwhelmed with the situation they're
not getting any help from the
administration then to top it off
they're now being attacked politically
by that Administration with the
fake viral photos of them getting
whipped and what I love about that story
is the photographer for that uh two days
ago told El Paso ktsm which is you know
local news station that him and his
colleagues didn't see any whipping at
all yet the by Administration ran with
it uh jensaki came out and announced
that the bind Administration is going to
ban horse Patrol in the Del Rio sector
and those agents that they are put on
leave
All Eyes
let's go to Super Chat see what the
audience has to say if you haven't
already smash that like button become a
member at timcast.com for that member
segment coming up don't forget it's not
just about that one segment we got a
huge Library you can click that little
magnifying glass symbol search for any
name you want boom there's all of the
crazy segments from over the past year
or so since since January so definitely
want to check that out
all right see we got Nikolai says hey
Tim would love to see Dave Smith and
Hassan on the next little debate you
have on timcast also a minute UPenn
worked there for 20 years and got fired
from taking the vaccine
um Dave Smith and Hassan debate would be
amazing they're both invited
um there you go there's the word uh I'm
pretty sure Dave would would absolutely
be on board Hassan I can respect is a
very busy guy but I'd love to have him
so if they're interested we should
totally do it
all right
Michael Fernando Melos has great show
Tim cast's crew heard of this Augustin
Carstens GM of the bis a key difference
with the cbdc is central bank will have
absolute control of the rules and
regulations bad vibes I'm not familiar
with what those things are bis is Bank
of international settlements which is
kind of the mother Central Bank of all
the central banks on Earth not all of
them but a big one in Switzerland and
that kind of you see the Federal Reserve
New York of Bank of England and the bank
of Australia funnel their funds through
the bank of international settlements
with no oversight
boom Martin says a great doctor once
told me that the wisdom comes from the
nurses they know what's up many doctors
are glorified search engines no actual
Authority interesting that's interesting
is that just that's true that is
actually correct so many human errors
have been caught by nurses so many lives
have been saved because they catch for
the doctors they're up to date with
their patients
all right
Jamie goodberry says is it New York City
or New York there is an unbelievable
difference and Upstate hates the city
that's true but uh they're um you know
they're in it that's right that's the
state I mean yeah what do you do should
the city secede from the state they
collapse in two seconds
all right Jonathan galtorini says for
George Eddie Guerrera was my first hero
LOL Latino Heat we always got to
represent love it make 1984 fiction
again says
Hassan has never added any substance to
any subject him having as many followers
as he does is a bigger threat than any
virus Dave Smith tore him up today it
was heavyweight versus welterweight wow
was there a debate or something I don't
know yeah I gotta check the on where
like on Twitch Hassan's been saying he
wants to bridge the gap politically so
oh that's well that's like because
anyone that disagrees with him is an
automatic white supremacist
yeah like that's that's yo if someone
comes out and says I have an issue about
X and then you go haha well why I'm like
bro quiet that was the same Playbook oh
what's his face Carlos Mazza ran yeah oh
on Twitter all the time Carlos hello
Carlos
whatever happened to him I don't know
dipped out he was in the spotlight for
about I know four months I know like the
whole Stephen Carter situation and then
it was just gone
Roberto Lara says two things Tim one the
cult is afraid of the unvax and the
anti-mandators and two we as humans will
never be perfect the only ones who are
perfect are our pets who look up to us
cheers gang I mean sort of
um is just like pissing all over the
joints so we had to just let him go
outside and yeah you know let him do his
cat stuff it's far from perfect he's a
much happier since we took that big
jacket off of him he started crawling up
on me now yeah he's not happier he's
happy with me he knows that I'm the one
I love that thing
now he's wearing a bell yeah that
Jingles you can hear him coming and he
hates it that's why he liked the armor
we had this like the silent thick
leather cat armor he's outside or
whatever all right curling up outside my
room
serp YouTube says Ian there's an
interview with Adam Stokes called The
Most Wanted Man in crypto check it out I
think you will find it interesting thank
you cool
Bonker says sometimes I hate legal
precedent because they'll say oh there
is precedent but it was unconstitutional
the first time we just didn't fight it
like we should have and thus is the slow
erosion of our rights yep
yep sell rinse as my college requires a
test every 14 days for the vax and every
four if you don't it's free at least but
you can't come to class without it you
also have to fill out a survey every day
to get into buildings I would just be
like nine doing it and then they'd be
like you're expelled I'm like okay
there you go
camel of the Mojave says the war on
terror is coming home and these people
need to justify their budgets oh yeah
[Music]
all right
broke uh brokage over hokages she says
I've been told my uh by my boss since
I'm a private contractor I may need to
get the vaccine since my dad is the
owner I will tell him that I quit if I'm
required wait okay do it your boss is
good dad no no no I think his boss is
not his dad his dad owns it but he has
someone
that'd be awesome
Gabriel Martinez says I bet Tim is
vaccinated everybody asks if he is and I
will respond with when was the last time
you had sex with your wife oh yeah
yeah I think my position is strictly you
go to your doctor you talked about
what's right for you in nobody else's
business
that one of the biggest problems I have
with the Mandate is that there could be
someone who's got like a weird medical
issue it's embarrassing and then you go
to the restaurant with your friends and
they're like where's your Vex card and
then you got to be like I'd like to
publicly answer all my friends that I
have a very embarrassing condition
that's right no it's not as anybody's
business yeah you know
all right let's see Nick s says Tim I
know you're joking but please stop
talking about how rich you are even
ingest becoming a little ridiculous you
see the point of it is not a single
actual leftist rich person will come out
and ever admit that they're exempt from
all of this so how do you get a regular
working-class person who's not paying
attention to to to wake up okay tell
them straight up yo if you're rich in
this country if you're rich in this
world you are 100
exempt from everything
so there's that Meme that goes around if
the penalty for a crime is a fine it's
only illegal for the for the lower class
but there are some countries that do
speeding tickets by percentage of your
income so that's brutal that is brutal
yeah like some rich dude driving down
and you know the road and he gets pulled
over and he's like all right let's see
that'll be a hundred thousand dollar
ticket oh that's bad
yeah it's brutal yeah but in the U.S in
uh like I used to live in Wrigleyville
near uh Cubs field
Wrigley Field
people would just park illegally
blocking my driveway like my apartment
or whatever because they were like we
don't care yeah
100 ticket cheaper than parking
so they would just say whatever they'd
be parked like double parked to the side
don't care they're not going to tow they
can't tell everybody so people just part
it probably still do it yeah
all right
Eric speed says hello please tell Ian
that they are both vented and unvented
n95 masks I also have Ian check out
heirloom wheat like Anson Mills thanks
for doing what you do Tim all right
there you go thank you t-bas says F yeah
that rant is worth my first Super Chat
see some people liked the uh you know
yelling at people because they're
letting the rich get away with all the
stuff that's good
the plague doctor says we don't get the
vaccine because we see it's not
effective and how many people have had
horrible reactions it damaged my heart
and since I can't get the booster shot I
am losing my career after them are they
mandating the booster for no we haven't
seen yeah just for all it's over 65 and
up on the booster yeah yeah FDA didn't
approve it for everyone yet that's
common it's coming yeah we may be
manifesting a dystopian future if we
talk about that it's already here it's
already here the future is never here
you know this is the present I think I
think we talked about with Luke
freedomastan did we talk about that on
the show did we last week no a while ago
yeah Freedom stand it means like Freedom
city is Stan mean City so um I think we
talked about like a member segment a
year ago well not a year ago like back
in February in Lucas here we were like
why don't we just get a big plot of
acreage in the middle of nowhere that's
like really cheap and then just start
like building stuff on we're doing it we
did it apparently there's some like very
wealthy investors that want to get
involved and I'm like I don't want
anything now we're gonna we're gonna
have this place and and it's you know
just big open acreage
freedom of Stan you know Freedom City
that's basically what it is I'm gonna
build a solar Road and show you that it
works
okay Ian raise the funds for a solar
Road
the mayor of Freedom now what does make
sense for a solar road is shielding the
road with
something above it with solar panels
around it and then it prevents some
weathering on the road keeps them dry so
you don't got assault and you don't got
to sand and stuff like that stops wear
and tear but you got to focus on the
solar panels above it so you'll be
basically building a scaffold over
road so I I write stuff about that
that's interesting yeah there's one of
those in Asia somewhere I was looking at
yeah like the whole thing is convo solar
panels it protects the road it has to be
but then you got to maintain the solar
panels on top so
all right
Juliana says Tim you need an app for
your website I hate supporting YouTube
to watch this on my mobile yes we are in
the process it's uh
not easy
let's see you know can only do so much
work with so many people
Trek God says you are only safe when you
are free I agree absolutely oh I was
thinking the whole point of cities is
kind of safety since the beginning of
time humans came together fleeing from
big bears and they form these little
villages to protect themselves you just
solved one of my main questions which is
why these big cities always turn so darn
blue and I'm willing to bet that it's
because it's more important to them to
have security than to have freedom yep
interesting ah nailed it when you live
out in uh in the middle of nowhere in
West Virginia we got a Facebook group
and they're like hey guys saw a bear
down at the you know at the turn and
then people like got it and they should
go with their guns
you know you gotta worry about it or an
air horn
y scare them away
Katie says hey Tim and crew thanks for
doing all the work you do even uh even
to y'all we can't see or hear
do you guys have any advice on starting
a website and your own server
uh I was reading about vented face masks
so starting a website and a server for
the fediverse project we're working on
Open Network Foundation is the name of
the company the charity that we have
just started and that's how we're going
to be doing it um I'm
yeah sure why not what do you have in
mind she was asking how to do it how to
start a server on a website just how do
you start a server on a website
the server thing I'm not too familiar
with
um I mean to start a website
Squarespace yeah Squarespace godaddy.com
pork bun.com but I mean someone else is
going to be hosting it for you so if you
want to host a locally you'll have to do
it you know on like hard drives
Raspberry Pi's you can set up servers on
Raspberry pies at your house and do it
through that
all right well once we have the the
fativerse project up and running where
people can have their own independent
websites that sink into all this stuff
it's going to be groundbreaking yeah we
could build uh Raspberry Pi's with
pre-loaded software that we could sell
hey look at this oh that's a good idea
wooden says you can walk across the
George Washington Bridge from New York
state to go to New Jersey state thank
you Tim hey there you go there
all right Damon Bullock says Tim my
sister is a medical worker in Central
North Carolina
she got her religious exemption and a
lot of her co-workers didn't they quit
principles over career Bravo wow
I wonder why she got it in the others
did it yeah I'm curious
Stephen Taylor says much love from Utah
First Time superchat gonna miss the show
during the elk hunt have fun well just
uh uh record it play it back later or
whatever TiVo eight yeah yeah TiVo yeah
Jared D says Ian and Alex Jones Vlog
adventure oh my gosh did you guys see
the cast Castle episode with uh little
Ian Alex Jones animation at the
beginning
the mushroom that was uh I highly
recommend going and watching is that the
one from the from after Alex was here
yeah it's clipped our voices from the
show and it's in the cartoons that's
cool we've got uh we have a one of the
Vlog episodes is behind the scenes with
Alex Jones and it's getting like tons of
views amazing man youtube.com cast
castle and um we're we're ramping up the
cast Castle production the events uh we
wanted to book an event we've been
struggling to do events because there
are like legal restrictions on what you
can do with certain zoned properties and
things like that and so we thought we
had solved it all and then we didn't and
we're like maybe we can do do a small
private friend you know um
you know what what what's I'm so old I
don't remember uh not a party but Soiree
no no no
there was a word for like it's not a
party it's smaller than that social
Gathering I suppose no but like maybe
like you know we were actually we had
some people we were booking and then
just
dude venues don't want a book dinner
it's hard you know you got to book it
way in advance and then some businesses
just don't care anymore right business
is too slow there's like I don't care so
we're like well to build our own we're
gonna build our own
Freedom estan yeah it's a ring to it and
we're gonna we're gonna have a big stage
and we're gonna do events it's gonna be
epic it's going to be really excited for
the underground what we're gonna build
underground yeah six stories down with
shipping containers
he wants to go he wants to build
um miles upon miles of maze-like
structures full of human bones I saw a
picture of a friend in the French
catacombs there's like a statue of a guy
coming out of the wall in the catacombs
yeah
that's creepy so cool so cool props to
that guy
Nathaniel [ __ ] says my wife cares about
this Gabby whatever it's the conspiracy
and and family drama she likes this
might be anecdotal it's real house
murder of camping USA yeah it's true
crime people love True Crime right so
we're the like all crime is true because
it happened so like this whole there's a
genre called True Crime I don't get it
that's just like reality TV crime or
something I enjoy watching uh the
interrogations like that to me is like
fascinating
um so I watched those like I could stay
up all night just watching those so
interrogation videos are great but he
was saying that guys like the
interrogation and women like the drama
of being a victim which was super
interesting
I don't know maybe yeah that's awesome
we got a new show coming out
um hopefully this week we're gonna be
having Shane Cashman on the show Friday
to talk about Mysteries and True Crime
and paranormal so true crime what
exactly does it mean it's it's unsolved
is that what it is it's like kind of
like the personal it's like True Crime
what you said like there's a genre
called True Crime because like in TV you
also see your you know fictional crime
so like so oh so like the O.J Simpson
trial people love Law and Order right so
imagine you know you like turn on a
podcast and then you hear like this
creepy music
and then a voice goes the year was 1953
December 1st the 17 year old boy walks
into a bodega New York I'm watching this
for for a bag of potato chips
[Music]
this is the story of the stolen potato
chips
and then you're like and then like
you'll hear the intro and then there'll
be a woman being like I don't know why
he took the chips why did he take them
you know and then it's like two hours
long and then they're like he spent 50
years in prison and then you're like oh
whoa and then it turns out he didn't
actually do it it was assuming the whole
time but they caught the seagull and the
seagull got the death penalty
is one of my favorite shows growing up
the seagulls stole the chips the whole
time still at large my son went to
prison because of that seagull
s all right you get those pictures of
the seagulls like dive bombing the ice
cream cones and the people like losing
what a villain yeah he came all the way
from London the seagull that annoying
one mm-hmm
all right well now that uh we're past
that distraction uh
Candace scalf says I love you Ian LOL
that's it that's the chat nice thanks
Candace yeah I agree that's a tweet if
but if that was it what's the point of
the rest of that you know it makes me
wonder if she she's being serious when
she says she I love Ian you never know
the women love Ian man yeah yeah we're
all humans humans first the Roz
Rodriguez says I work at the Texas
border with the unaccompanied alien
children that are crossing the average
of children apprehended is over 400 a
day yep wow man and then are they just
released yeah I think I was reading
numbers it's like over 400 a day and
around 570 get released into the United
States every day which according to the
New York Times one of those three micro
children are gonna get lost in the
system wow so compassionate Eric Allen
says I thought that college students
were supposed to be idealistic and
willing to Buck the system
maybe each comes and goes in waves you
know no they rage for the system now
yeah yeah that's cool now
Master gamer says Tim would be better to
protest by not voting at all to show any
hidden motives the Democrats would
reveal messed up my first superchit well
there's an interesting argument I say
stand up for what you believe in don't
just give in and let them sweep through
but there's a lot of I guess I don't
know what the right word is how you
describe these people there's a lot of
people on the right who are like it
would be better if the Democrats win a
sweeping super majority across the board
because then it would force all the
Republicans in the country to snap into
some kind of action and then cause some
kind of divorce or Civil War or whatever
yeah I don't know if that's true or that
would happen but a lot of people are
like you know when Trump comes out since
it's rigged what's the point and then
people are like I don't care I'm not
gonna vote I mean it's true if the
Democrats control literally everything
independent voters and Republicans are
going to just recoil and then there will
be a huge Snapback so maybe maybe if
we're lucky there I mean yeah we kind of
saw the the emergence of the of the tea
party after Obama we don't know if uh we
need another one again we'll see
Jason cisnero says the company next to
my company's office requires all
employees to be vaccinated and tested
daily
wow that's horrible daily like that
thing up your nose every day
Hana Magi says Tim it wasn't just on
Tick Tock a lot of Gabby patito's
friends in the North Port area were
really pushing it hard on Facebook and
the local news ABC 7 nbc2 wink Florida
I'll show you in a message on Twitter if
you'd like uh interesting Anno says
America is going to collapse so bad and
it's going to be hell in this country
with all these people cartels gangs and
the culture War BS all this is done on
purpose in the name of population
control I'm not entirely convinced but I
think you know certainly the climate
change people have have strep said the
best thing to do for the environment is
not have kids so there's certainly that
element I think it's funny somebody
chatted saying like if Tim thinks he'll
get out of this unscathed huh it's like
when have I ever said that I'm like no
it's gonna get bad I'm that's why I'm
buying beans that's why we have
emergency beans because I'm pretty sure
it's going to suck for everyone but you
know what I got chickens we have 15
chickens now you know why a lot of
people don't understand this but if you
buy chickens and put them in the same
place for an extended period oh my one
day I'll come out more chickens
yes ma'am do you just feed them grass
and just eat a lot of eggs I mean that's
incredible technically you know like you
can chickens just live so as long as you
can protect them with enough space they
will eat bugs all day and then they'll
have babies but if you give them feed
they'll have babies faster interesting
yeah our chickens are fat and happy Oh
yeah and so we have eight babies
from The Originals we had six then we
adopted another one so we had seven and
then they had a bunch of babies and
Dorothy the adopted chicken is brooding
so she's all like puffed up and wide and
like with a weird look on her face
sitting on the eggs here's the problem
though she's been sitting on the eggs
for a few weeks and nothing's happened
and I'm like these eggs are you know
this happens they may be unfertilized or
bad and so what we may have to do is
clear out the eggs and she probably
won't stop brooding we'll have to then
take the eggs and incubate them then
when the babies are born pick her up put
the baby underneath her and then she's
like here's the peeping and goes like
whoa and then doesn't realize we did all
that yeah
we've been raising uh we raised this
like these five chicks in in the in the
green room where we play music and one
of them is singing one of them sings he
picked it up last night and it was sick
it's like a movie yeah yeah a unique
sound that none of the other chickens
make so one of the so we have five black
star chicks it's a Rhode Island Red
rooster with a bar Plymouth Rock hen we
have two girls they're jet black like
that's that's what happens the girls are
black the boys are barred meaning
they're white and black and of the three
boys one of them has a chirp that is
like I've not heard from any of the
other chickens so while the babies go
this one goes like
oh it's like a song we're gonna breed
him yeah so I'm like that's the one we
want to keep we want to have and then
what we do is we get that one he grows
up he will you know fertilize all the
other you know eggs and then once those
eggs are born we'll wait and listen to
the ones that sing properly and if they
don't we just get you know we call them
you know what I mean like I'm kidding
well quite literally that's what so
we've had people on the show who have
chickens and we're like what do you do
with the roosters when they're born like
you call them yeah like at factories I
throw them in a grinder because like you
can't have roosters so we have we have
five male we have five males now we have
one rooster and then the babies the
cockrells so we can maybe keep one of
them the uh Roberto's firstborn son is
Roberto Jr that's what we named him
his name is Roberto Jr and he looks like
him too good babe yeah we we nicknamed
him snaggletoe because his toe was bent
the wrong way it was like a birth defect
yeah as a birth defect but we call him
his name's Roberto Jr and then we have
uh the the two so there was uh uh a girl
was born from Margaret and Roberto then
from Katarina and Roberto and then
Margaret that's the order they were born
in okay and so the second born baby was
Roberto's firstborn son
earplugs last night I'm prepping for the
move of chicken City because it's gonna
be yeah basically outside of my bedroom
window oh boy good luck with that I'll
let you guys know yeah yeah
all right let's read we got uh Gus Gus
he says 170 employees I work at Legacy
Health in Portland Oregon and they just
denied over 800 of us medical and
religious exemptions Thursday is last
day wow that's gonna be a big story
that'll be huge where's that again Tim
I'll try to read a book Legacy Health in
Portland okay yep 800 people yeah but
how many are going to be like okay I
guess I'll just yeah get vaccinated and
then it'll end up being like 70 people
fired Maybe
Commander Trashman says I'm a pharmacist
at Novant last year we couldn't mask
talk about covet or be fired now we have
to or get fired noventus Ultra woke our
admin brags about the leaders of being
about the leaders on vax mandates wow
Cody wheeler says everyone knows about
the cart knows about the cartel grows in
Cali but nobody is talking about all the
cartel grows that popped up in the in
southern Oregon I work at a plant
nursery in Klamath County and earlier
this year we had a sixty thousand dollar
soil order
well then oh my yeah they're in
Washington state they're in Oregon
um but they're like wreaking havoc in
California because of that prop 64 and
that uh knocking down illegal
cultivation from uh misdemeanor to a
felony
yeah yeah here's a good idea for you uh
Jorge beef nasty says you thought of uh
you thought of making replicas of these
bracelets to sell to spread awareness
donate profits profits to stop this
something I can physically show to
family to spread the word because it
might hit home stronger than just
another story no that's that's a
fantastic and that's why I haven't even
brought this here because I just want
it's it's a game dream when you see it
in person it's real but that's a
fantastic idea actually that's a great
idea I like that yeah these are dirty
they're staring on them yeah yeah but
make replicas and then you know sell
them for 20 bucks and have all the
proceeds go towards so like human
trafficking organizations no no like to
to anti-human traffic organizations
I don't know why you'd want to support
them
you you walk up to the human traffickers
we raised all this money for you it was
like uh thanks a bag of money yeah we
all pitched in to help
you know but maybe if you give one of
these Smugglers a million bucks you
might quit and be like I'm retiring yeah
right like they're doing it for
desperation because they need money a
lot of this money tell us everything's
all money money money money
a lot of money Hayden says everyone
should read the storm before the storm
the beginning of the end of the Roman
Republic by Mike Duncan I believe the
immigration in Rome was during the
collapse of the Empire not the Republic
the Republic collapse is more in line
with us oh so we're gonna become the
Empire
I like that title already the storm
before the storm is that what happened
the Republic collapse and became an
Empire yeah the Empire Julius Caesar you
know invaded the capital and took over
basically and then like hundreds of
years later the Empire started crumble
in all this migration from the Huns of
like 580 or a little bit before that
from the Northeast wow okay gotta check
that one out I gotta get on my like I
gotta start reading about that stuff
swimming with the Haitians yeah Heath
Hansen says migration crisis huge part
of the collapse of Rome the Huns caused
a huge shift of Barbarians that crossed
borders and multiple waves that the
Empire struggled and eventually failed
to manage interesting it's incredible uh
Kings in General's YouTube channel look
it up on them and watch the Fantastic
documentaries about it okay yeah I'm
going to check it out yeah listen to him
Derek Elwell says hey Tim I finally
became a member last night is there any
way to watch the members clip live and
if there isn't will there be an option
too soon we record those they're not
live broadcast the member segments we
record and then upload so they're
different done differently I guess we
are going to be having so here's the
plan
the new show we're launching probably
this week I think is basically ready to
go we're just setting up the accounts
now to make sure everything's in line
and we have the domains and stuff and
then we're going to have Shane Cashman
who's the writer for the mystery show on
Friday to talk about just a bunch of
really cool stuff True Crime Murder
Mysteries the goal the point uh the show
is going to be there's like a 15 to 20
minute show with full sound effects
music when you know like I was
explaining to Ian but more seriously so
when you have you know Shane doing voice
over and he says you know I was walking
down the street at night investigating
in a car drives by then you'll hear the
actual car pan from left to right and
all that cool sound effects and then for
the members content we're going to have
Shane hanging out with one of the
members of the crew and potentially
other guests talking about the story and
other issues around it so one of there's
one thing we really hope to do with with
Alex Jones if he's ever interested in
you know and coming back on which would
be awesome is to have Alex sit with
Shane discussing one of his stories and
conspiracies because it'll be
fascinating for Shane
who was actually he actually travels and
does on-the-ground investigations we're
actually investigating a story about
Confederate gold to then hear you know
Alex Jones talk about his knowledge of
all these crazy stories and experiences
would be fantastic the other thing we
want to do with Alex is just put Alex
and Ian in a room and turn the camera on
and we'll all leave and just I would
watch that I feel like I feel like it's
like it would be like when you turn a
camera on and point it at a TV and then
you get an endless like recursive Loop
of the how to watch the screen you'll
see images of Thomas Jefferson and the
Illuminati and Ben Franklin swirling
around Ian and Alex talking would like
create a a hyper time spiral as you're
watching it words would slowly become
meaningless they'd be like shaking like
crazy and there'd be light emerging from
the center of the room and you'd be like
what Alex's dad was like they wanted him
to join the basically they wanted to
co-opt them into the deep state but he
wouldn't do it accordingly so his dad's
like right on the precipice he knew you
know he saw a lot and Alex listened to
it as a young man I remember Alex said
that I think said the first one was on
the show that they've tried to recruit
him but he doesn't want to do it and I'm
like that's one that we can't fact check
I don't know if I believe that that's an
animal like he knows I don't think
there's like an Illuminati that shows up
your door and knocks and is like would
you like to join us and say in the world
Alex was like I'm not gonna do it I just
don't believe something like that would
happen granted I don't think it was that
you know cartoonish there may have been
special interests who are like hey look
you know play ball I do know that Vice
for instance had phone calls from the
state department about some of the stuff
they were doing and well yes yeah but
then of course look you know Joe I think
Obama and Biden had they went to the
vice office or I I don't know about
Obama but I think Biden did and uh uh
they interviewed Obama so they were
totally on board with the establishment
agenda you know what I mean
there it is yeah psychic energy is real
we we have not had anything like that we
have no uh uh there are a lot of
billionaires apparently heavily
interested in frederastan because the
idea like me like Luke was talking about
it we're talking about having like this
place where we would just be like set up
a small little spot where you can live
and it's like a freedom Community or
something and apparently there's a bunch
of like wealthy investors that were like
we want to be involved in that and I'm
like but we don't need that kind of
support you know what I mean we don't
maybe you know how about you buy the
space next to where we're at and you can
do your thing that'd be cool and like
we'll do our thing yeah they probably
got some agenda behind it too I don't
necessarily think I mean maybe the
agenda is freedom you know but we don't
need we don't want to create that kind
of community we want to create a
community of someone who's going to like
build a mud hut
and then live in it and be like I enjoy
this and we'll be like that's cool like
someone who works really really hard and
is totally self-sustainable and like
homesteading from a Hut they build
themselves oh that's great what's that
YouTube channel that dude that like
builds ancient technology or whatever is
that what it is so good it's like a
spoon I gotta look it up yeah build a
freaking Castle
all right let's read a couple more here
takumsa says Yuri besmanov was right
that's correct so I hear
Siegfried says in lighter news Tim
thanks to you and another Super Chat for
turning me on to Etta furretta love it
it's an anime it's really good I should
watch more of it it's pretty cool
um so if you guys want to check that out
there you go and uh let's see what we
got here primitive technology
he's fantastic there you go so cool
all right let's see g-money says hello
timoth I left my job at B4 and mbb uh to
start my own consulting firm to help
small businesses thrive in the upcoming
Industrial Revolution Siebert strategia
very cool yeah cool all right here we'll
do one more Matthew Vance says Navy Seal
in his dress blues was shadowing Millie
today even sitting behind him while
testifying what was in the briefcase he
was carrying why isn't the nuke football
with the president why is it with the
JCS great work
huh that's a good question
well my friends thanks for hanging out
it's been a blast make sure you go to
timcast.com become a member we're gonna
have a member segment coming up just
around 11 or so p.m tonight you can uh
subscribe to this channel like this
video share the show with your friends
you can follow me personally at timcast
you can follow the show at timcast IRL
do you guys want to shout anything out
yeah um you know follow me on social
media on Twitter it's Ventura report
Instagram is Jorge Ventura TV you could
also subscribe to the Daily Caller
YouTube where our documentary on these
cartels are going to release next week
so I'm really excited for it because we
like so we did a deep dive we did more
um we just went full on like try to give
you guys as much footage no local news
even when like would step up to a cartok
or anything so we've stepped up to him
film them flew drones on them did a full
thing so we're excited so stay tuned for
that and also you know we're gonna
continue our border coverage obviously
we still have a crisis there and we're
gonna give it as much attention as it is
so we'll be back in Texas so
um I'm sagnikbassy you can follow me on
Twitter at sagnikbasu s a g n i k b a s
u and like George said uh just keep an
eye out for the documentary uh we put
like a lot of work into it our safety
you know we ran into some cartoons as
like as like a journalist reporter or
producer whatever you want to call it in
DC I've never had to experience like
these kind of situations ever so this
was like a force for me and yeah should
be out next week yeah so the stakes were
high and the product matches it so
where's the documentary going live it's
gonna go live on The Daily Caller
YouTube in all of our channels but we're
gonna promote it everywhere like we'll
we'll have it out it's gonna be
um yeah it's gonna I think it's gonna be
very informative because I think a lot
of people don't know about about what's
going on though thanks for coming man
thanks for coming dude um this is uh
thanks for bringing these two because
this is hit home I want to remind people
like this was on someone's arm or their
ankle yesterday last night yeah
just shows like they're just Commodities
as of now well this is commodity number
4186 that's a lot of Commodities thanks
again thanks for coming I'm continuously
impressed with the work of these guys
doing um so I'm really really looking
forward to this documentary it's true
it's 100 True your documentaries have
been great especially from the ones in
California you talk to those parents and
business owners and whatnot you guys may
follow me on Twitter at Sarah patchlitz
don't forget to smash that like button
on your way out and go over to
timcast.com we will see you there around
11 11 or so p.m thanks for hanging out
bye guys